foreign
[Music]
hey everybody what's going on it's
[__] Finally Friday night God damn it
yeah again this seemed like another very
long week
well camera's [__] weird today isn't
it well we were using it last night um
yeah because we were doing streammate
laughing yeah it's just strange it's a
different
um you have a different tripod yeah and
it's in a different position and
that's that's more the way it is
that's better okay you sure yeah that's
more okay I know the microphone's in
there but that's all right it's getting
the arm is getting to the point where it
won't really stay up anymore
how about now
oh okay so back yeah you know what
happened when you moved it you pushed
the button and turned it off I think
okay was there no sound the whole time
or just because I think when he just
moved it I think he just turned off
there's a button
they're saying yes okay
sound now okay sorry about that was
there was no sound the whole the whole
show
could have been yeah okay yeah all right
well that's what I was thinking it's
probably just because the that's the
thing about this microphone it's cool
having it on the arm and everything like
that but that button is right there so
it's like you go up there to move it and
you're always just like and you always
like turn it off like accidentally
because I do that all the time too
Thomas just saying that he felt bloated
today and I told him he looked fine yeah
and I told him he looked fine I think
that's always that right that was
important
it wasn't the whole show yeah yeah
that's so it must have just been when
you moved a microphone
um so I wanted to say uh Hey DJ Maniac
who is he said he's at an industrial
show with Anastasia yeah which is which
is a friend of ours yeah she used to
live down here I hadn't seen her for a
long time but yeah she moved to
Australia for a little while didn't she
yep we did a video over yeah that's
right yes uh back on the old uh
our Gothic Orlando
um uh YouTube show remember we had that
yeah that's right yeah she said a couple
of the a couple of videos I showed it to
him
yeah that's pretty cool it's back when
we were all children when we were all
children yeah
well I mean I was still like in my late
30s or 40s so I wasn't that much of a
child but you know yeah we were like
comparatively I think I was very early
40s comparing it might have been 41.
um Oracle says well I have some good
news and some bad news good news my
contract got renewed for another three
months that's awesome
that's awesome contract on what job
contract okay
yeah yeah
um but there's bad news too I'm assuming
so
yeah
bad news a friend's husband of nine
years died of a heart attack
in his sleep on Monday it's the same day
I was with my husband at the doctors for
a second round biopsy holy [__]
how old was he
I can't imagine that's got to be so
shitty I mean I know it can happen like
people could die anytime but yeah I
don't know that's [__] shitty
I was thinking about I don't know why I
was thinking about that but
because I was thinking about what you
said when you went out in that
motorcycle the other day and it was
[__] up
but then you said you backed out the
motorcycle from the garage today and it
had a flat tire yeah like had a nail in
it had a nail in it yeah
and that was on the running motorcycle
yeah
man 56 she said he was 56. 56 okay [__]
a couple years older than me yeah
yeah it was uh
there was a nail in the back of my
[__] motorcycle tire
so I didn't I did a big No-No I pulled
it and [__] plugged it like with a
car plug car tire plug that was supposed
to do that
but uh
that tires
a few months away from being replaced
anyway so
gotta get new tires for that one
I got that throw out bearing for the
other one so I'll be able to do the
transmission job
we'll see you we told them
he got the nail we're assuming yesterday
because yesterday when I got home yeah
he told me he's like oh hey I cheated on
you with that Chinese chick again yeah
he went to Ichiban without me yeah
yesterday you were at work I know and I
was like oh you suck I had to get some
of that
hahaha
and apparently that's when you got the
nail on it so today like he's backing it
out he was gonna go to the go to Oasis
and the nail was in there I said Gee
that's what you get that's what you get
for cheap for food cheating yeah
whenever I'm talking about cheating
it's going to going to restaurants
without her
just like meanwhile I'm sitting in my
hot ass car in the work parking lot like
eating tuna salad on crackers
and he's in there like eating it [__]
yeah eating the Chinese buffet Chinese
food Mexican food that's right and I
still haven't gone to that Mexican place
oh yeah I'll take you down there I mean
we should go there one of these days
it's just that we always end up going to
Ichiban because
um you know the bookstore is there the
coffee shop is there like the movie
theater is there in case each one's
cheaper and it is cheaper yeah
yeah that Mexican place yeah you're
lucky you might be able to get away with
twenty dollars a person
really it's that much yeah man the
[__] portions I've only eaten there
one time and that was when that girl was
visiting us that British girl yeah it's
it's a lot and that was a long time ago
it's got a much better cook a much
better menu
so they kind of fancied it up some
um
well the food food yeah I didn't
necessarily mean the building because
I've seen it from the outside it still
looks kind of diving but that's okay
yeah well it's kind of a grocery store
too like I'm one half that's a real
Mexican restaurant yeah
but I love Mexicans go
yeah yeah but you said the food was like
a lot better now I mean it was good
before like when I ate there better now
but it's better now yeah
half naked you said now I want my cold
lo mein I don't think I've ever had lo
mein cold but that sounds like it'd be
kind of good
I like cold noodles no I don't think
cold lo mein would be good
well I guess some people might like I
guess it would depend yeah
what Oracle was saying about um yeah the
guy who was 56 uh said there are worse
ways to go yeah it was sudden but he
didn't suffer and their dog was sleeping
next to him yeah it's like it's it more
it sucks I guess for ever but for the
family you know what I mean because it's
like
you weren't expecting it and then all of
a sudden the next day yeah
yeah it's like that's what I mean so
that's kind of nice
but
yeah I wonder if the dog do
oh yeah I wonder
think a dog would be able to sense it I
mean you'd think
because don't they don't they say don't
they have those like cats and dogs that
like hang out in um like Rest Homes and
stuff like that maybe some of them like
know which people are gonna die next and
stuff like that yeah that's a different
situation though he died of a heart
attack yeah it wasn't anything that's
true build up to it but you would think
that once you died a dog would probably
detect that pretty quickly yeah you'd
think yeah they got a real sharp sense
of smell I imagine you could probably
smell the change
yeah
that's weird to think about yeah
I just thought if I died in the house
the cats probably just eat me
[Laughter]
this was uh
might have been around Chicago or
something
they didn't know what the deal was uh
the house
they didn't know if the house is
abandoned or what and it was in the
middle of a kind of a downtown type area
went in there and there was a [__]
skeletal old lady I'm just bones and she
had fallen behind a damn dresser
yeah I remember hearing about that
couldn't get couldn't get out of there
and both her cats were in there dead too
sitting on the windowsills couldn't get
out that's horrible yeah
so if you die
your pets die with you
but anyway uh they're not sure when she
died because she paid for the house so
she didn't have anybody
and the electricity was still on
but they think it was years
that she was in that house
that's crazy yeah it was a two-story
house
Oracle said their dog's name is Cookie
ha
that's so cute that's pokey's uh
official name baby Cookie every now and
then I call her that Phil or
Snickerdoodle I call her that sometimes
too
um
let me see
Gen X Jason says should I give two weeks
notice to quit my shitty job or just
bounce
well you might want to use it as a
reference I mean there's yeah there's
two schools of thought on that it's like
because I'm in the I only have one week
left at my job too and I did give two
weeks notice like technically you don't
have to there's no law saying that you
should but if you want to maintain a
good relationship if you need a
reference or something like that then
it's better to do that on the other hand
if it's really shitty and you can't
really take it anymore and they've been
shitty to you and you're not planning on
telling anybody who works there then you
can just leave you know what I mean it
would be fine
Camp guy said I think the power gets
left on at some places that dude that
tours old abandoned buildings finds the
power on all the time yeah see that's
what I always wondered it's just kind of
like I guess maybe it doesn't make
enough of a difference for anybody to
really notice or care but
yeah because didn't you say like they
found some abandoned mansion like in the
middle of nowhere and it's like the
power was still on and that had been
abandoned for like years years yeah so
I'm like who the [__] is still paying
for that [__]
City I guess
this is well they're not paying it it's
just that
no one's noticing no one noticed yeah
which is weird because man when I was
growing up and like
you were in arrears on your electric
bill for like a month or two they'd come
and like turn your [__] off yeah so well
places like Detroit
um they leave the power and the water on
no matter what because there's there
aren't any employees to turn things off
right so they're just like yeah whatever
it doesn't matter
and um
the winners get pretty bad there if you
turn to the electricity off people would
freeze to death yeah so uh I know that
as Detroit was just kind of being
consumed
and people were just leaving it you had
a whole subdivisions were just empty
empty uh abandoned
houses
and they were all tore up you know
people going in there and vandalized
them but the power was still on in them
yeah that's pretty weird hours on on all
of them so is the water
hmm
yeah Camp guy said Georgia power would
notice if I was one day late yeah I kind
of feel like
if we didn't pay the election bill on
this house they'd be like
not gonna return your [__] off Detroit
at one time I don't know if it still
does
um at one time Detroit
had signs it says enter Detroit at your
own risk there is no there is no Police
Service
that's it yes it was it
was like something model damn predator
you could go down there and commit
multiple murders and
no one would call the cops
bodies would just be left there
came out of my uh apartment one time
said it many times it was in the winter
pass by the dumpster going to my car and
there was some [__] feet sticking up
out of the dumpster
Shoes Gone
yeah yeah
killed some black dude and they threw
him in the [__] dumpster
which is just drug war and that was
before Detroit was really bad
I was living on cast corridor
[__] second West Hancock
what place is [__] spooky had a lot
of fun there though I had a great god
scene
but then later on I heard uh this is
like
not long ago maybe 10 years ago I heard
they were putting up signs since you
entered Detroit in your own risk that
there there's no police protection
it just is
in that whole city and there weren't any
cops
they had a police station but
not enough cops to answer calls they
didn't answer any calls right and it
wasn't a fully
it wasn't a fully uh
populated city as you would know it
anyway it was like a ghost town in most
areas
at least in the areas I guess when they
did that
was pretty wild
and then they uh they tore a lot of it
down
most a lot of it's not there anymore
yeah
Gen X Jason says I'm from Connecticut
the anus of New England that's what I
want to talk about yeah it's like I
don't know that whole two weeks notice
thing because I've kind of looked it up
before too because I was like you I
don't I know you don't necessarily have
to do that especially not in Florida
but I don't know if that's actually
required
you know what I mean yeah I mean I guess
it would be dependent upon I don't think
like it's a law anywhere but I mean I
guess it would depend too upon like
um maybe the employment contract that
you signed like because I know that some
jobs they make you sign a contract that
says you know if you're going to leave
you have to give us this much and blah
blah but I didn't sound anything like
that but I just thought it would be like
a nice thing to do just in case you know
because I didn't want to be a dick I
don't you know I don't want to just like
take off and like leave everybody in the
Lurch you know what I mean because
that's like kind of shitty
but
so that's why I did it then goes Detroit
you're saying I don't know what he's
talking about yeah I haven't seen
grafters in in a while in the comment
section but yeah I haven't either now
that I think about it we went to school
for a little while together in that area
he knows all about it he's got
I don't think it's a Detroit cop though
but it's not there anymore really not
the Detroit that I know that's gone
uh it's evidently torn torn down
I think the downtown area is still there
but a lot of the neighborhoods that are
rounded evidently aren't there anymore
so if you ever watch uh you see uh uh
Dan Bell and when he does little tours
of Baltimore it's much worse than
Baltimore
yeah Baltimore looks pretty spooky
the Detroit was much worse
yes wasn't there it wasn't a functional
City
it was like post-apocalyptic
abandoned skyscrapers
abandoned Subway systems that were just
[__] just a gaping black hole in the
ground he didn't want to go anywhere
near that place
old factories just sitting there
um
and it wasn't crowded at all it was like
vacant
Tammy said they wouldn't give you two
weeks if they fired you yeah that's a
good point that's why I'm not really
like I said I more did it just because
you know I don't want to be shitty to
like people that would have to
you know that would get behind on work
because I wasn't there you know what I
mean but yeah you're right like don't
and I kind of like nowadays that people
are because remember back in like the
50s it's like you know the Boomers and
stuff and they were all like real loyal
to like the company they work for and
stuff like that and I was just like [__]
that [__] why they're not loyal to you
so why should you they were back in
those days that's why they were like
that you know
it's like if they you know if they can
[__] just come in and be like yeah
get out then it's like you shouldn't
worry too much about them
people don't keep jobs the way they used
to and I don't blame them to be honest
well people the jobs are disposable and
the people are disposable
yeah there's no way you know all this
you're gonna be a company man and work
there 20 years and get retired and
they'll take care of you no long gone I
mean most people just work a place like
one or two years and then move on to
like somewhere else you know what I mean
yeah like hopefully to somewhere like
better that pays better yeah it's not
supposed to be that way it's just part
of the damn disintegration of of the
society you know the the politicians
that people vote for don't work for you
they work for their donors that keep
them flush with money and the donors
[__] wanted to use them to break up
the unions and to ship all these jobs
overseas because people here were
using organized labor and union labor to
try to keep wages High
it's one thing the Democrats were good
at back in those days was unionized
Labor
but then they they sold out now they got
the Democrats trying to have open
borders which is the exact opposite
and that that's just like something the
Koch brothers and [__] real hardcore
industrial Republicans would want is
open borders because that way you could
just continually flood the labor market
with cheap labor and prevent the [__]
the the prevent labor labor unions from
Foreman
so you know it's a license to steal
the the rich people have turned the
money pump on they're just pumping all
the money out of the middle class and
the lower classes they're getting richer
and everybody's getting poorer that's a
sign of the [__] times that that's a
sign of end times when that happens it's
a cycle
all civilizations go through it
it ends bad always
it's what started French revolutions
[__] Russian Revolution
um you know it's just
it's dead
the rich people are either gonna have to
turn the pump off and let people [__]
make money again
or the or the rich people are gonna have
to be driven out of power
some way
it's not going to be done through voting
they own that system
Ben says I'm I'm assuming you're maybe
you're asking me
but did you tell your co-workers about
your new vocation no I don't know them
well enough to do that they don't matter
no that's that's what I mean it's like I
wouldn't they're not her generation and
they're not really anything like her so
just a bunch of old bitties well no not
all of us yeah but I was like still it's
like I wouldn't yeah that's like not
appropriate for the workplace I'm
guessing it's like I don't know them
well enough to say that anyway
uh half naked you says UPS requires it
two weeks notice um if you want rehire
status that is not sure why you would
want that uh yeah see I don't know I've
never worked for UPS so I don't really
know if that's any good or not Ryan says
is anyone here seen Harold and mod yes
I've seen it like several times I
actually I actually love that movie I
don't think we've ever reviewed it now
that I'm thinking about it I've seen it
in a long time oh I love that movie so
much I've seen it a bunch of times I
used to have it on VHS back in the old
days so these people don't know what
it's about
it's about a love affair
between like a guy in his late teens or
early 20s and a woman in her maybe late
70s which is she she's probably about
late 70s I think she was yeah yeah it
was Ruth Gordon yeah who was the same
woman that played um many casts of it in
Rosemary's Baby in case you're wondering
yeah it's it's it's a fun movie
um it's a dark comedy yeah they're both
oddballs yeah and um it kind of works
out but they're both weird it's a good
flick haven't seen it forever I forgot
how it ended I remember how it ends yeah
I'm not spoiling I don't yeah I'm not
gonna spoil it but I remember since I
was a teenager yeah Oracle said y'all
should review it yeah we totally should
because that's honestly one of my
favorite movies in the era like Bud
court is so [__] great in that he's
all like more of it and like fakes his
death all the time and [__] like that
that's why when we re-watch Ginger Snaps
the other day where they're doing all
those fake death photos and stuff I was
like I wonder if that's where they got
the idea from yeah from Harold and mod
because that's what Harold was always
doing
like doing all this fake like faking his
death all the time to freak his mom out
he was a teenager overseas I thought he
was 18 or 19. yeah or like I thought he
was like college age yeah like college
freshman right like I thought but I
haven't seen it in a while either but I
thought that that was like they were
trying to get him to go to college so
I'm guessing he was like 19 or something
yeah and he makes a girlfriend who's in
her 70s yeah and she's all like
free-spirited yeah she's nothing like
him physically
you look at him
but there's some kind of attraction
between them it's been a long time since
I've seen it they were ended up being
kind of a cute couple yeah
um
they were having sex too yeah there's
there's like a love scene I think yeah
yeah yeah
yeah it's not like real graphic or
anything but yeah I remember it being
kind of like stylistic they were like in
bed together yeah type of deal smoking
cigarettes
John Gore said Bud Court uh never
recovered from that movie
I mean I guess it's so iconic he was in
other stuff after that but
I don't know if he ever really like got
to the same
height is that you know and he was real
young in that film too and then Ryan
said he basically invented emo yeah he's
the proto-goth he was kinda yeah yeah
when what year did that movie come out
late 60s 65 66 something like that now I
can't remember I think so I think I
thought it was early 70s but I could be
remembering it right that was late 60s
Maybe
because I thought oh well maybe not
because I was gonna say Ruth Gordon was
in it and she was in Rosemary's Baby and
Rosemary's Baby came out in 1968 and she
looked like pretty much the same yeah
but we watched it in high school
yeah me and Steve Ross 1971 yeah I
thought it was early 70s so it was two
years so it was three years after
um rosary's baby
yeah me and Steve Washington in high
school we were tripping on it we liked
it I think I watched it in high school
too but I watched it like a bunch of
times like in the 90s and stuff
yeah it works and she just looked it up
yeah I could have sworn it was like
early 70s
but I was thinking like 1972 1973 so I
was a little bit off
um Ryan says I have a horror film review
recommendation the sadness
um I think you'd have to go look on the
channel I think I did a review of that
like um on my flickers of fear series if
I'm not mistaken because I remember
writing about it on my blog and I think
I did a video of it too that was a great
[__] movie though that was the one
that like super gory one right about the
it was kind of like a zombie movie but
it was like an infection Style zombie
movie there was some [__] up [__] in
that it was um
job was it Japanese or Thai
I can't remember
because it was a while back that I
thought you probably like it actually
did we mention on here that we watched
um that somebody a long time ago
recommended this movie but um what's it
called like muscle bodybuilder in Hell
or yeah like that what the [__] is the
name of it bloody muscle bloody muscle
body builder yeah something called
bloody muscle bodybuilder because I
think it's on shutter
and we were like going through shutter
the other day and I said oh somebody's
somebody a long time ago like asked us
to watch this and I was like we should
probably watch it yeah it's the Japanese
Evil Dead essentially it's not like evil
dead yeah and homage is Evil Dead
several times yeah I mean very very
obviously
and uh
it's about a guy who uh he he lifts he
works out
he's a Japanese guy
he doesn't really look like he works out
a lot but he he works out some I guess
so I would really call him a bodybuilder
kind of like novice gym rat
but it's a pretty good movie
um and not expect like [__] high
budget I mean it's ultra low budget real
low budget and it's like an hour long
yeah but it's uh
the movie's from the heart and it is
entertaining as [__]
so that that's that's its strong points
if you like the Evil Dead you'd like it
it's more of that yeah it's it's real
cheap like I said it's super low budget
and it's like I think it's even
um in four three aspect ratio I don't
even think it's in like movie aspect
ratio yeah but um so it's like square
but it was yeah it was a lot of fun yeah
okay the sadness was Taiwanese that's
right it's been a while since I've seen
it but I'm almost I'm 95 sure that I did
a video review of it maybe
I think I remember watching it
like several months ago I guess I don't
remember but yeah I had a bodybuilder in
hell
he eventually to fight the demons
the undead the evil Undead yeah
he had a he had a shotgun for a while
didn't he yeah and then he just like
just like Ruth Camp yeah and did he have
a chainsaw also
I don't think he ever I kept expecting
him to get a chainsaw but I don't think
he had one
but he ends up
making a weapon out of barbells
yeah yeah that was well it's just
because the whole movie he's like trying
to fight the demons with other stuff but
then he's like oh well I need to fight
him with my yeah which is my thing yeah
yeah
yeah Ryan says uh look into that
director yeah I wonder what he ever
whatever happened to him yeah I don't
know it was the 90s or the 80s I think
it was the 90s but or maybe lady it
looked older it did but remember we were
watching
um I was on 2B the other day and they
have like a a vast
um collection of MST and Rift tracks
episodes and I was watching one the
other day that I think they just put up
and it was this movie called feeders
and I'm watching it
it was set in Pennsylvania yeah super
super low budget and we're trying to
figure out like what year this came out
because I was like this looks like 80.
it's like it looked like ass and well
it's just like kind of like early 80s
yeah it looked like early 80s just and
just like from the clothing and the
hairstyles and stuff like that and then
like I guess like the rift tracks guys
were kind of like making fun of it too
like it was from 1982 or something like
that and then Kevin says uh this was
made in 1996 and I was like holy [__]
holy [__] like this something was wrong
they showed a Mustang in there and it
was from an early 90s Mustang
early 90s Mustang GT Fox body and you
could tell that they really really
wanted they probably made the whole
movie just to put that card put that
card they were proud of that car they
were yeah there was numerous parking
scenes and then like parking it and
walking away from it it was an alien
invasion movie
and the aliens were little
puppets actually were they technically
even puppets because I don't think not
in a puppet in the sense of like you'd
be sticking in your hand up and spot and
like moving it around I think they were
just like Shake yeah they were like this
yeah nosy and they're like killing
people so it's like there'd be a scene
where somebody is like laying down with
a bunch of like fake blood on them and
this tiny little alien he's like
it was like an alien it wasn't really
like a puppet
I think they had a rod in it so it could
move its head baby I don't even know
and then they were kept like
they just had girls in there that they
knew and they would do things like show
a picture of them walking through the
house and it would zoom in on their
[__] feet as they were walking like
quietly and you look and it's just
busted up old tennis shoes yeah like
gross dirty sandwiches yeah you know
that's like somebody had a gross dirty
tennis shoe fetish or something
um Ryan says have you all seen a Serbian
film
um
I've seen bits of it I don't know if
it's necessarily something and I'll
watch like [__] up horror movies I
don't have an issue with that I know
what happens in it because I've read all
the synopsis and I've seen like all the
um you know I've seen Clips around and
stuff I don't know if I'd like want to
sit through it necessarily because I
feel like it'd be one of those movies
it's like yeah I don't really need that
[__] rattle around in my head you
know what I mean I think that's pretty
much the only like super disturbing
movie that I haven't sat all the way
through
you know I've sat through most of the
other ones I don't know enough about it
to comment
it's basically
um
pretty much like all the worst most
depraved [__] you can think of is in
there
you know what I mean
and there's like a lot of controversy
about it because a lot of people are
just kind of like oh you're just like
putting all that [__] in there's like to
be shocking for the sake of being
shocking and the filmmakers are trying
to come up with like this kind of
um well I don't know they're trying to
come up with like some of the oh it's
symbolic of this not the other which
maybe it is I don't really know but you
know we're always talking about this
chair it doesn't make any sense that it
yeah it [__] bands backwards there is
a control back here it looks like it's
for that
yeah now I'll try to lean back in
so yeah that's what it was oh all right
well that explains it yeah so you can
open it like and lean it back and then
you can lock it okay yeah because that
didn't make any sense to me that I liked
it because I'd be like leaning back
accidentally sometimes they'd be like
and I was like well so now that didn't
make any sense yeah but there's a
there's a lock for it
and it could lock in any position you
want okay
see observing observing [__] observing
observing
John Gore said I just saw a kill list
from 2011 that's a great [__] movie I
really liked that a lot
um I think I reviewed that one too if
I'm not mistaken same director as Meg
too yeah that's right I forgot about
that
I forgot about that uh have we seen
Killer condom we have not
um although that definitely sounds like
something up my alley I still haven't
watched I'm still tempted to watch
rubber the movie about the killer car
tire
um I think it's on 2B and I just keep
scrolling past it and I'm like
one of these days I'll be in the mood to
watch that but I don't know killer
condom sounds like something I should
probably watch
hey Dave what's going on
uh gonna go to mannequins tonight yeah
we haven't been to mannequins in a while
got so
got so sad drinking to do two great pro
wrestlers died this week oh yeah right
oh [__] okay well have a couple drinks
on them then gonna have a few drinks for
him
yeah how's it been
I mean didn't didn't they say that they
were gonna start charging like um uh
cover charge and all that and how's that
going I mean we haven't been in a while
so I don't really know we went to
Barbarella
a couple weeks ago
like we went to we did we went Saturday
night and then I think we went to
Memento a couple week or two ago
whenever they had that
actually I think they're having another
Memento next week but it's gonna be on
Sunday night because next Monday is
Labor Day yeah
yeah 60s Ram said kill list is awesome
yeah I really really like kill lists a
lot
yeah that's the same director that did
what's his [__] name Ben Wheatley
right well I'm not the same guy that did
a field in England which I also love and
field
inning that's the same guy right
that was a weird [__] movie I think I
reviewed that one too
what was the other one that he made
didn't he make one more
that I'm thinking of I know he did field
in England I know he did Kill list and I
thought there was like one other one
The Killers was good because spoiler
alert if you haven't seen it but it kind
of starts out like a um like a real
violent like crime movie but then it
goes like folk horror and it's like it's
pretty cool
man that red grapefruit's good I know
even even the kind we got and this is
the Dollar General brand yeah it's like
three dollars Clover Valley or whatever
their brand name is it's like a three
dollar [__] hat gown not even three
dollars then it was two dollars and 25
cents or 2.59 or something like that
with her big ass bottle we each got one
Ryan says the Serbian film has a good
plot yeah it does a psychological
Thriller about a former porn star is an
interesting concept but they didn't have
to go too far and that's what ruined it
yeah it's to me it just kind of seemed
like from what I know about it and from
the bits I've seen of it it just seemed
to me like and I'm not you know I'm not
averse to putting whatever the [__] you
want in your movie like within reason as
long as it's not real you know what I
mean
um but there comes a point where it just
seems like to try hard and I don't
really like try hard you know what I
mean it's just kind of like yeah we'll
put all this [__] up and [__] and then
somebody rapes the baby you know what I
mean it's just kind of like okay
you know what I mean it just seems a
little like trying too hard to be edgy I
guess
John Gore said Serbian film is okay not
great it's no video drama
yeah I'm more into I really I like if
I'm in the mood for
um you know quote unquote extreme horror
or disturbing horror then I like a lot
of that because I've seen like I said
I've seen most if you go to any list
that says of most disturbing horror
movies I've seen probably 95 of those
and you know some of them yeah are
[__] up
and I read a lot of extreme horror too
like books
but I don't know I kind of have to be in
the mood for it because normally my
favorite genres are like I like haunted
house stuff I like
surrealist kind of stuff like ambiguous
type of horror psychological horror I
like that kind of stuff you know
John Gore said Wonderland is a good take
on the John Holmes story liked it better
than Boogie Nights yeah we um
we did it we did because we did a show
about that case that that was based on
um the one with the uh the drug dealers
in the house yeah so we watched the
movie it wasn't too long ago actually
you'd have to remind me of what was in
the movie
well yeah it was John Holmes and these
other guys and they were doing this big
like drug score and then like a whole
bunch of people ended up getting killed
yeah yeah I vaguely remember because
Boogie Nights Boogie Nights had a scene
like that the whole Sister Christian
thing where everybody was getting shot
with the drug deal and everything and
that was like a fictionalization of that
but Wonderland was kind of more based on
the real [__] best porn movie was mope
yeah that was that was another one based
on a real
story that was actually kind of like the
movie it's good because it starts out
kind of funny but then like it goes like
horrific where it's still kind of funny
but main character isn't losing his mind
it's horrible what happens because I
feel sorry for him I feel bad I did too
but yeah yeah it was just it was pretty
[__] up how that whole [__] went down
killed his friend and then end up
killing himself basically
yeah it's it's [__] up it's [__] up
um Brian said there's a story I plan to
write that's like perfect blue and a
Serbian film but more like perfect blue
we should we still haven't I think we
haven't reviewed perfect blue yet either
and I think that's also on TV that's
anime
um about a porn star with a personality
disorder with mysterious murders
happening around him and a ghost that
sounds kind of cool actually
yeah you know like let me know when you
write that I'd be interested to read it
Ben said did you see Candyland I don't
think so worth a look I thought it was a
drama about sex workers at truck stops
but it turns into a full-on slasher by
the end
see that sounds intriguing
that sounds intriguing Camp guy said I
just smoked some home cured pork belly
bacon slices in cook the end pieces came
out good yeah best I've done or right up
there okay good that sounds really good
actually
we had a we had was like roast chicken
or baked chicken yeah for the last
couple days I made a salad I pulled some
greens out of the garden yeah Super
Fresh yeah it was kale
fresh kale
and um
sweet potato greens yeah that's what it
was with the green with a green pepper
that was grown out of there one of the
small ones that didn't quite come out
all that good because I think I might
turn uh the other green peppers into uh
stuffed bell peppers I got that oh got
that hamburger down there thawed I
haven't had stuffed bell peppers in a
long time that sounds really good yeah
they're not very big though that's the
only problem they're not well you could
just make a lot of them yeah no there
are not that many of them no there's not
that many
hmm yeah you just make them as like
little side dishes yeah
I went down and buy some at the store
too
yeah that's true yeah every now and then
I used to go and get
from Publix they would have they have um
you know there's ready to cook
stuff they have all laid out for you and
they have stuffed peppers I think
there's like four or six like and they
do them all out for it's fresh and you
just take them home and stick them in
the oven and
one of the things I always wanted to
learn how to do is uh
smokers I never really got into smoking
I'd like to learn how to smoke
and I'd like to be able to make burnt
ends remember burnt ends yeah man I
haven't had those in a while I haven't
either now that I'm thinking about it
never made them only bottom boy that cat
is loud
she loves that [__] cat box
she she just went in there
yeah see I think she goes in there to
play to hang out yeah because I hear her
in like farting around in there all the
time and it's like it's not always
there's not always like poop in there
yeah she's going there to check it I
think she's just going in there to like
fart around and play Yeah because
sometimes I walk past and she's just
kind of like sitting in there like
because then I'll go in there too where
because the the one that I have up here
that she uses Pookie won't use it but um
it's called what is it called The Breeze
system or something like that and it's
just like this big green and white thing
and it has
um like pellets in
it yeah you hear that
[Laughter]
don't stress her out
and she
said she's gonna sit there it's like
throws all the it like scratches into
one side and scratches
yes you don't stress her out when she's
licking it because she'll get like all
she'll get self-conscious about it
walking in a circle
[Laughter]
that new kitty we got is like is a trip
yeah she's like but I'm trying to like
her and Pokey are getting along
it seems like right yeah I mean they
seem like they're kind of getting along
but here's one thing look she just ran
back in here she's right she's running
circles hey what's up
um here's one thing
they're fine they don't fight or
anything really but if Pookie sees me
petting the other cat
like this morning like the other cat
came in while I was getting ready for
work and she's like you know rubbing on
my leg it's like hey hey and I was just
like hey what's up and I guess pookie
was like down the hall and was like
watching and then when I walked down the
hall later when I was leaving I went
down to pet Pookie and she went and ran
off like she she was like don't touch me
yeah and I was just like oh that made me
so sad it makes me she's jealous yeah
she doesn't care like that like I said
they don't fight and they don't seem
like they're mad at each other or
anything like that but it's like if
she's if Pookie sees you petting the
other cat she gets very very upset
and I you know and I don't and it and it
makes me really sad and I don't know
what to do about it do you know anything
about it well I know but it's just kind
of like I mean the other cat the other
cat who like I said when she came from
this shelter
her name was Dakota which that's her
solar official name but we were just
calling her Bambi because she looks kind
of like a baby deer you know what I mean
like the way she walks in her butt and
everything so um if now if I'm petting
Pookie then Bambi will run over and be
like hey I want in on that action but
not like mean you know what I mean she's
like I'm gonna be petted too and then
Pookie gets mad she's like [__] this and
then she runs up
you can't Pat both of them at the same
time they just they won't have it
we found out I don't know if we um if we
said this
but last weekend
we were at the bookstore
and every so many weeks at the bookstore
they have like a big pet adoption event
because you know there's a pet smart
right there and the people from uh it's
called hofmeyer animal shelter animal
rescue or something like that and they
come there and they bring like a bunch
of cats and puppies and stuff like that
and everybody comes and looks at them
and they usually it seems like they
usually adopt some people some people
they adopt some kitties and stuff out
like we saw two cats get adopted while
we were there so um
so because we knew that Bambi had come
from
hofmeyer like we asked the lady there to
look her up for us
and she said that this is crazy but
Bambi she's only 14 months old but she's
already had a litter they said and they
think that that's why because I guess
didn't she say that um that she had been
surrendered yeah she was in a Kill
Center yeah like in Tampa yeah
and she had been surrendered by somebody
I guess because she got pregnant and had
babies
and whoever it was dropped her off like
at this shelter which they called a high
kill shelter that was in Tampa but the
lady said well sometimes this um shelter
will call us and be like hey we have
this many accounts like can you take
them yeah cats are suitable for adoption
like they're young you know what I mean
right and hofmeyer is like they they're
animal rescues so they don't it's a
shelter but they don't
them yeah so they just try to adopt them
out
so she had been there she had been at
hofmeyer since what'd she say May
yeah so she'd been there for like a few
months and then like they sent her over
to PetSmart and then that same day that
they sent her over to PetSmart that was
the same day that we saw her and they're
an adopted her yeah so
Tammy said Pookie don't want no other
Kitty germs on her yeah like that's what
it is it's just making me so upset
because I went down to pet her like that
and she was like
and then she just like took off don't
touch me
it's like petting other kitties she just
can't take it it's like it's so funny I
mean it's not funny it's like it makes
you sad but you know what I mean it just
makes me sad she'll get over it she
won't even remember it I know but
they're running up to each other like
that and then smelling each other's
mouths yeah like what do you got
I guess
another thing too is that Bambi like
eats an amazing [__] amount I just
can't and she's so skinny she's so
little and skinny and it's just like
I'll put two dishes out
like because presumably because I want
Pookie to have one and like Pookie will
come around the corner and like eat it
and she's just like no I'm not eating
next to that have you feed him separate
now no I'm gonna I'm gonna start doing
that tomorrow feed him separate but
we should all put two plates down and
that and Bambi will just like plow
through bushes and then she moves to the
other one and then just eats all of that
and I'm just like God damn it I come
over all the food is gone and that's
like a can and a half you know what I
mean
um Camp guy said I'm glad my stray cat
is a male I took him to the vet and got
his shots uh but he's outside on 110
plus acres so hoping he doesn't bring
another cat around
yeah that said he may bring a female cat
and or babies around if I don't get him
fixed it's always better to get them
fixed because you don't want to like
knock up
some other cat and be responsible for
kitties and all that kind of stuff
I think even a lot of shelters will
will go around and like pick up stray
cats and
um they fix them and they'll fix them
and then let them go like if they can't
be you know if they've lived outside for
a long time and they probably can't be
acclimated but we don't know they
weren't really sure because we asked the
women were like well do you know
anything about
um the home where she came from
um and they didn't really know because
they said well we just got her from the
shelter so we don't know what happened
before that but um
I said well she must have been
somebody's cat she must have lived in a
house or something like that because
she's really
friendly you know and she's not afraid
she knows what a litter box is she likes
being in a house she doesn't seem to
want to go outside or anything like that
and she's not
skittish She's Not Afraid of people and
she's not afraid of other cats either
so I'm assuming she doesn't seem like
she was mistreated or nothing I don't
think so no no not at all I mean because
as soon as we brought her home she was
just kind of like oh yeah cool and she
was like rubbing on us and she knew what
a house was showing us her belly and
stuff like that so it's like I don't
imagine that she's ever been mistreated
in her very short life
but yeah
um let me see
Tammy said uh my hubby found a brindle
colored Chihuahua mixed dog abandoned
along the road to his uncles a couple
weeks ago that city was probably only
five or six months old I just can't I
mean unless the animals run away I can't
imagine just like abandoning an animal
like that
it's crazy
Mandy said I have a fluffy black cat who
I adopted five years ago and she's
always been teeny tiny yeah I think some
breeds are smaller than others because
when we got pookie
you know she's a Manx and the new cat we
got is a Manx also and they actually
don't get quite as big as other cats and
it takes them a long time to get to
their full I think Pookie didn't get to
her full size until she was four or five
years old and um and she's still not big
I mean she's a little chubby because
because of all the all the Temptations
she eats but um you know but she's small
she's got like little short legs and
stuff like that and Bambi she's I don't
you know she's only 14 months so I don't
know how much bigger she's gonna get
she's got much longer legs than poop
he's got
she's not
Bambi's Not A banks but she's not like
she doesn't have that little manx like
roundness
and like the little short legs like like
um looks like a bobcat yeah she she does
actually look like a bobcat a little bit
like the coloring and stuff
I kind of feel like Pookie is more like
the classic
makes
all ball you know yeah like that's what
Coco the gorilla had a Manx kitten and
that's what he named her
like all ball that's what she named her
because she's just round head and like
round body
oh
Ben says a friend recently invited me to
a fancy Yogurt Bar oh that sounds good
they had an auto mat type system where
you choose different types of frozen
yogurts from nozzles into a cup then add
the condiments and stuff oh yeah we used
to have a place like that
the mall we used to go but I think it's
closed now it's like he was showing off
tasting them all so I got my cup and
totally filled it slushy Style with
matcha green tea yogurt
he turned white and said they'll charge
you fifty dollars for that it apparently
was by weight I quickly discarded my
yogurt cup got a normal one away left in
a hurry oh you're gonna get in trouble
like a big golf size thing like that and
they're just like that'll be a hundred
and three dollars sir
Yogurt by weight oh my God that's funny
um lace Mandy says Ah a small chubby
kitty yeah Pookie's a little bit chubby
I don't like to say that too loud
because I don't want her to get like
self-esteem issues she's fat
but I'm gonna put that cat on test don't
don't do that
I don't know why I don't know why she's
well I guess it's all the Temptations
because she doesn't eat a lot of wet
food thank you thank you Gadget they
they they they get fixed and when they
do that all their [__] endocrine
system kind of shuts down they they put
on a lot of weight they become eunuchs
basically I mean because she runs around
and stuff she's I mean she sleeps a lot
but she's fairly active as in running
around and whatnot doesn't matter but
the androgens aren't there
but we she does eat a lot of Temptations
yeah
but the thing about Temptations is that
they're certainly regular Catholic yeah
they're not um I think they're only two
calories per piece yeah it's regular cat
food that's
and she doesn't eat a lot of wet food
because I'll put wet food out in shoes
let's just like take a couple bites of
it be like meh
what was that uh Super Chat what did it
say
uh it says totally forgot hey guys
getting Stella to playing Farm Sim and
hanging with my kitty oh that's awesome
Ryan said have you all heard of the
Spielberg horror film that was never
made called night skies yeah wasn't that
okay now please refresh my memory
but wasn't that eventually turned into
something else
like the idea for night skies
what am I because I know that we did a
review of a movie not too long ago and I
was like yeah this was the movie that
originally was going to be nice guys the
Spielberg movie but then like they
turned it into this other movie
and then Spielberg didn't direct it
though no I don't think so
unless it was unless it was E.T
no because we didn't review ET
I haven't seen ET since it came out
in the theater in 1982
and I don't think I've seen it since
then maybe I saw it one more time since
then
um yeah Ben says now I tease him about
one more than all you can eat yogurt bar
so all you can eat yogurt that's just
like really fun anime like thinking
about the [__]
uh Tammy says both our cats showed up
here as Strays six years apart had them
both fixed and they have just stuck
around they're now inside outside cats
yeah prior to us getting
um the cats we have now
every cat I ever had growing up just
wandered up to the house and stayed
like we never when I was a kid we always
had a cat but we never
went out and got a cat we just always
had a cat because
one would die or something like that and
then like another one would be like hey
I'm your new cat like about a week or
two later it was like there was a little
cat Network that was like Hey that that
house is like catless you need to get
over there and
that's yeah so I think that's what
happened
but yeah Pookie we got from
a family friend
who found her apparently that's the
story anyway
but I think that Bambi is the first cat
that we actually went out and like
adopted
from a police you know what I mean yeah
and we've been talking about it for a
while so yeah Ben said apparently bits
of it became E.T and Poltergeist yeah
see that's what I thought
I thought that's what it was
Kaylin said I still think it was very
irresponsible to release the Dark
Crystal the same week as E.T I have
forgotten that those two came out the
same week why is that irresponsible
why because the Dark Crystal is so much
better I don't know man I love The Dark
Crystal I love that movie that's the
thing too
huh the thing in E.T came right that's
right yeah you released at that time
although we were talking about that the
other day about how
I mean that kind of the thing coming out
kind of soured John Carpenter on the
whole like movie making experience
because
he thought it was like his Masterpiece
which it is in hindsight and um but
nobody really recognized it as such at
the time which is crazy now like
thinking about it
but
it's the same kind of thing where
the [__] when The Shining came out in
1980 it got nominated for like Razzie
Awards yeah they know what they're
talking about no
I mean how like that's one of the best
movies ever made
obviously
I don't know it's it's just one of those
movies and I don't know why it's old
people I guess
what would they know
I don't think they were Boomers
yeah maybe not
yeah people just really seem to get it
I think that well it seemed like the
main criticism of the thing at the time
was that it was too gory
it was like too much you know what I
mean which one the thing the thing yeah
and I was just like yeah you know
there's almost y'all know fun
there's this well there's certain type
of people that just don't there wasn't
hardly any blood in it they don't
understand or they don't appreciate I
guess the Artistry of horror movies yeah
you know there wasn't even any blood in
that most of it was green yeah
yeah you know I mean there's something
it wasn't gory it was just like a
grotesque I guess is a better word yeah
the alien transformation
killing plant animals are plantable
it's just like we were talking about
that that movie The mutations that we
were talking about the other day yeah
yeah oh Kalyn said uh clarified we met
by irresponsible it said oh Henson
versus Spielberg Dark Crystal lost a lot
of money because of that I think a lot
of movies that came out that around then
lost a lot of money because of that it's
kind of a shame like when one movie
comes out I don't know they don't plan
it I know but one movie comes out and
just like [__]
Stomps all over all the other ones like
nobody goes to see the other ones
They delayed Dune two till next year oh
did they really for some reason yeah I
just saw that um well we just saw the
trailer a couple weeks back yeah I
thought it was coming out in November
some people are saying because they're
going to release it as a summer
blockbuster
no maybe that's what they said because
they thought it would do better like in
the summer time evidently evidently the
the story around the production of the
center of the second movie is that it it
went well real well better than the
first one
that they liked it
so evidently whoever owns that movie is
going to hold off on it
and release it as a summer blockbuster
which made me think how much you want to
bet they re-release Dune one
yeah they probably will the month before
well I mean I kind of wanted to re-watch
Dune one before we went I saw June 2
anyway because it's been a while since
it makes a lot more sense if they just
wait till the next summer released Dune
one and then the next month dude dude
too because a lot of people didn't see
Doom one
in the theater yeah we did yeah but
so I have a feeling that's what they're
gonna do but it's been delayed until
next year yeah
evidently because uh because they liked
it so it's not a bad thing it's a good
thing
they think they can make about more
money with it although I kind of got the
impression that thank you very much
Jeffy art about to head to work by the
way Pookie isn't fat she's rubenesque
dating
[Laughter]
she has a little pouch though that
swings back and forth when she runs yeah
she runs into [__] belly does that
and it almost touches the floor because
she's well because her legs are only
this long she has little mini short legs
and she's like she has like a funny
little run in her little belly because
like it's so [__] cute hopefully
they'll give each other some exercise in
here they are chasing each other well
see that's what I kind of thought I
wanted somebody that would
like another cat that would play with
her and like run around and you know
they would like entertain each other
um
yeah uh they're saying they're still mad
about uh Dark Crystal losing all the
money because E.T came out at the same
time
but Ben said Dark Crystal did okay for
home video release yeah I kind of feel
like that was one that sort of built up
um Word of Mouth like after it came out
on video and like on cable and stuff
because that's when I saw it I don't
think I saw Dark Crystal in the theater
I did see ET in the theater because my
parents took me because I was only 10.
Ben said I saw night shift for the first
time recently the Stephen King one of
the giant rats infesting the factory uh
the one with Brad dwarf in it yeah we uh
we reviewed it not too long ago yeah
I mean it's not one of the best Stephen
King adaptations but it was pretty good
it's just a horror movie yeah low budget
horror movie kind of thing
yeah there was a couple good decades man
uh good movies
and really uh Steven Spielberg George
Lucas and the [__] the new whiz kids
and I would think Dino DiLaurentis
studio also had a lot to do with it
very inventive movies were starting to
come out and it's because the 70s
was getting pretty stale a lot of stale
cop flicks although there was some good
70s movies late 70s movies
that came out
um I would argue that the 70s is
probably the best decade for movies uh I
think 80s but I mean 80s yeah there's
I'm not going to argue with you about
that I mean and even there was good
stuff in the 90s it was still getting
pretty good
um just well the action
genre kicked off in the 80s Arnold and
[__] uh Stallone and those guys that
that was cool but if you were a guy if
you were a young guy you were really
into that [__]
[__] um Karate Kid Karate movies
um
then they had pretty good science
fiction movies you know aliens
Terminator
Predator a lot of good [__] was coming
out
and uh
you know it's
it won't happen again it's just the
media isn't the same well everything's
been done
everything's been done
and in those days everyone was being
channeled into just theater
video games didn't compete
yeah [__] Netflix didn't compete with
movies
really the the main forms of mediums
if you were young in the 80s and the 90s
it was movies and [__] records yeah
Maybe music videos
you know it wasn't until internet came
out and then it took a while for that to
actually
become a medium to itself you know it
was a medium but it was just real
primitive
um David Bowie predicted what that
effect would have
Billy Idol also said a bunch of stuff
that turned out to be true about the
internet
just um
I don't know
late 70s all through the 80s
and part of the 90s it was just a
kind of a
big explosion of creativity and high
quality entertainment in movies and the
records were [__] high quality too
I mean it had metal bands and metal acts
that would spend millions of dollars
just to engineer an album
that's how much money was in out in
metal or any music
you'd never see that today
I mean
a Duran Duran album might cost over a
million dollars to produce
well in their videos we're super
expensive too yeah and then yeah not
even counting the videos just talk about
the rate the record
but they knew they were going to make
all that money back
and then the tours and everything hell
yeah
that's why it sounded so good
you know they had
[__] expert
musicians
and writers picking through that
material over and over again to make
sure everything was just spot on
and that it would make it would have
Focus
Commercial Success you know it still had
artistic success they're like seven in
the Ragged tiger [__] almost a near
Perfect album Rio was almost [__]
perfect as far as a commercial vehicle
just to sell records it was just that
that album was so [__] slick
I kind of lacked texture it was so slick
Rio you notice that uh well every song I
don't know who played well I don't know
about that because there were a few
songs on there that didn't really get
any play but I find that when I'm
listening to Duran Duran that's almost
always the album so although it's
between that and the first one because I
really like their first one too I like
seven in the ragging tiger well yeah
they're all good but I'm just saying
that I listened to the first one and Rio
the most often that live album Arena I
could listen to that over and over again
yeah that came out in 85. [__] love
that album
that had the only Studio track on that
was wild boys yeah
but the rest of it yeah that was live
yeah
yeah they got a really good um
they really The Sound Engineering that
was really good like it was really clear
and I'm not usually and I'm not super
into live albums
that album was but that was a good one
yeah
I don't know why I've just never been
real into live albums well there's some
really good live Judas Priest albums
though at least in the East is really
good and that other one that they had
live meltdown was [__] fantastic uh
there are some good live albums out
there I like
um the live uh Nick Cave and the Bad
Seeds yeah it's just called live seeds
that's a really good live album I like
that a lot I listen to that a lot but
what I think was best about live Judas
Priest is that
the live versions of some of the
greatest songs from the 70s have been
updated
you know what I mean so they've updated
some of those sounds they were better
live from the 90s than they were
recorded in the 70s
just sounded really good
yeah I like when that happened yeah like
updated versions of the Ripper or
updated versions of tyrant and genocide
and all that so I can
free uh [__] updated versions of
[__] hellbent for leather
speaking of which
I was gonna say look at this is when I
was at the bookstore last week
I got this
yep
so I haven't started reading it yet
because I'm still in the middle of um
of slew foot but
I'm probably gonna read that next
although I still have like three other
books over there that I haven't started
yet but it's like I don't know they only
had one copy of this we saw it a couple
weeks ago and I was like man that's
probably like really interesting
maybe I can like read it to you
that would be fun
I could read it out loud
you can go ahead and [__] uh unsub
that's just [__] dreams
go ahead and observe
yeah no I love Duran Duran yeah [__]
great out great oh and look what else
look what else I got today I got my
MST gizmoplex yes because I gave them a
couple bucks when they were found in the
the thing
so they gave me some stickers yeah I
just got those today too
yeah Ben says ASMR readings
well I guess
Tom is like um you don't really like to
read books because your eyesight's not
that good yeah
and um
so a couple times like I've read because
I bought him a book um it was Billy Idol
right yeah I got about halfway through
it and then I never I I liked it but I I
couldn't get back into it yeah it kept
getting distracted by the things
I just still got my place mark on it so
I probably should just like read it to
you out loud yeah yeah
that would probably work better yeah we
get into bed but you read to me a poor
bit
that'd be kind of good that'd be kind of
cool she used to read me books [__]
yeah it did and [__] we start
laughing and start talking about it and
then she go back to reading
what did I what was that what was that
one that I already oh man I forgot I
forgot two of them I think yeah I read
you
um
you were wanting to read it so you
decided to read it out loud to me yeah
yeah
I forgot what it was I forgot what it
was too yeah
I forgot what it was yeah I think it was
it was non-fiction yeah but I can't
remember what it was
a long time ago
but I'm just I I love to read yeah but
um well your audiobooks do pretty good
too yeah yeah she reads it you know does
her own readings yeah I kind of I like
to read out loud
and I've gotten more into because before
I'm not really I don't like listening to
other people's audiobooks especially if
it's fiction I feel like I can't
concentrate as much if someone is
telling me the story like I usually like
to read it so because it's
I don't know it just keeps my mind from
wandering but one thing I do like
listening to especially when I'm driving
is scary story it's like I like the
scary story channels yeah and I found
that
um especially when I'm driving to work
in the morning when it's like still dark
out and it's like kind of creepy and
there's nobody else around like I really
really like just listen to them and it's
like I really like I think I've said
before but I really like um Busta who I
think is he's Australian I think and I
really like his voice but there's
another Channel that's called let's read
and that dude has like a really good
voice he actually had I listened to one
on the way home yesterday that was he
did a compilation I think it was an hour
long and it was all quote unquote Karen
stories
so it was all people's run-ins with but
they were all like creep like they were
still like creepy stories where he was
like [__] crazy people you know what
I mean but they'd call them Karen
stories and it's like they were pretty
funny
but they were also kind of horrifying
but I like those he doesn't like a lot
of True Crime too like he talks about
um a lot of True Crime cases and
[__] like that like mixed in with
stories that people send him
um let me see
Ben says that Bill Hicks skit in The
Waffle House you're reading why do you
do that so I don't end up working in a
waffle house yeah I remember that it was
Bill Hicks he's a comedian yeah a very
famous comedian
uh he's dead he died several years ago
but uh yeah he's really funny but um
yeah that some people are like really
weird about because I used to take books
to work with me all the time and like
read in the break room and people are
like really weird about it I don't know
why
they're just like what do you reading
why are you doing why are you reading
why are you reading that and it's like
and then they'll come in and like talk
to you when you're clearly trying and
I'm just like obviously I don't really
want to talk to you I guess they
associate reading with like going to
school
I guess and you know you hate going to
I didn't well I hated some people I
hated it I hated I hated Junior High
yeah I liked high school though
I liked high school but I hated studying
I just thought it was not interesting at
all
one thing that was interesting was ass
[__] those girls in there that was it
[__] boys should not be in high
school
they need to be doing other [__] and
then they come back and [__] 23 or 24
when you're [__] hormones are not as
bad maybe 21. then they then they should
[__] complete it
I don't know I always really liked um I
mean even before I went to school like I
learned to read when I was very little
and I was just like really into it I
hated it and honestly like I had read so
much by the time I went to school that I
didn't usually even have to study all
that much
like everything came pretty easy my
thinking of this is why do they have me
sitting here learning things that people
already know
like this is already knowledge that
people already know why why do I have to
know it
you know teach me something that they
don't know you know I mean well how are
they going to teach you something they
don't know because nobody knows they
don't know it yet but that's what I was
thinking but see you have to like you
have to know everything that people know
so you can jump off from that you can't
just like come in and be like come up
with [__] at that time I didn't care
I didn't care well obviously no
I just I didn't even like being indoors
or like sitting still pretty that
didn't care I like some of the Hands-On
stuff like I liked biology
you know because we were doing uh
dissection yeah I like that
I liked uh
I liked drama I'm doing acting in
theater I like that it had to be kind of
physical
I liked a lot of I liked most of my
stuff I liked all the Sciences I like I
did some
um I did uh I was in chorus so I did
that so I was in some stage Productions
and stuff like that singing and I did
that and I really liked anything to do
with like English or
um literature or anything like that I
was totally down that was usually my
favorite and I was I didn't like history
until much later
they don't teach it very well I don't
know about now because I've been to
school in a long time maybe they've
gotten better at it but I always thought
like history is so interesting if you
teach it right but they don't it's just
it they just teach it to it's just like
a very dry
um you know recitation of facts and
stuff that you're supposed to like
memorize for the test or whatever most
of it's lies well and well most of it is
just not it's generic that it's not true
that's what I mean well they need to
like get more into like the context or
like the why things happen because
that's what's interesting it's not you
know not necessarily interesting it's
like what exact date something happened
on or what exact people were involved
it's like the context behind it is
what's interesting so that's why I got
like way more into
um I liked it in school but
um it's a lot more when you can um kind
of go off on your own and like read
stuff
it's a lot more interesting history
could be made very very interesting
if people knew what they were doing and
I'm sure that there's like some teachers
that are better than others too but like
I said the way when I was in school
everything was just they're like
teaching for the test you know what I
mean so you could pass the act or
whatever the [__] it was so it's like so
everything was just like a checklist
it's like well you have you need to know
this that and the other thing so they
didn't really get too much into
like the interesting [__] behind this
[__] they were just like teaching you a
bunch of facts that you needed to like
regurgitate on the text on the test you
know which is
nobody nobody likes that nobody likes
that I just kind of wish they would
to make it more interesting people a lot
more people would
be a lot more engaged with it if they
made it a lot more because it is
interesting but you have to like present
it the right way you know
but yeah I don't know people always
I've always been very bookish and for
some reason people are very suspicious
of that like certain types of people are
very suspicious of that
it is like because I've always found
that it's like this baffling
it's baffling to me
I don't know
but I've gotten back a lot um back into
reading a lot more recently
Gadget said glad you said that he
thought the grand Ram was the [__] was
shite except for Hungry Like the Wolf
and the one with the boobs the one with
the boobs that could be it that could be
a lot yeah man you go back there go back
and listening to [__] dredge Wren
lyrics especially like the notorious
album The Dragon Ram was about hookers
and blow basically I mean pretty much
that's what it was about
is mostly about prostitution it seems
like every song was about some girl
salad
or just trying to screw her away to the
top of a company just that's kind of
what it what that whole [__]
album was about
Joseph said have you ever read the
ceremonies by Ted Klein I don't think I
have now I've read some other stuff of
theirs but not that one
gaji says history over here was awesome
until we caught up with ourselves and it
turned into politics still past my
higher exam yeah I was actually way more
into
um because when I was in high school and
like I said it was a very long time ago
because I'm but um they had
they had a whole year of American
history
which makes sense and then you had a
whole year of like world history which
in practice was mostly just European
history with like oh yeah and then there
was some [__] going on in Africa and
Asia too at the same time you know what
I mean it's kind of but um but it was
mostly European history but um
I kind of found European history more
interesting
I guess because it wasn't as I mean the
American history stuff like we knew most
of that stuff already and a lot of it
was just like Puritans and stuff and we
were like boring like that you know what
I mean because the Puritans were they're
not a fun people
so um no there weren't very many of them
that's you and it's like and I was like
wow these guys sounded like real
miserable [__] you know what I mean
like from all their writings and stuff
because I remember we had to like read
all of their you know sinners in the
hands of an Angry God and like you had
we had to read all the Puritan stuff and
all that kind of stuff I was like wow
these people seem really fun at parties
what's funny is that everything was
American history is very ethnocentric it
was the the the history was told from at
the Anglo Viewpoint yeah the that's not
the history of the South during the time
that all that was going on the south was
spayed and we there were people here but
it was Spanish Empire in the French
Empire had nothing to do with them
[__] Bible Thumpers up there in New
England that's what I mean I kind of
feel like the American history class
like all like the the main focus of it
was like the Puritans yeah and like you
know the the English settlers and it's
just like they didn't talk hardly
anything about the Native Americans they
didn't talk anything about the French
settlers the Spanish anything like that
yeah well they well it's it's from a
British Viewpoint and they're totally
going to ignore the [__] Spanish and
the French Empire they don't want to
talk about that at all well see that's
why like but I mean living in Florida
like we didn't have a Florida history
class which might have been interesting
but living in Florida it's like the
history of Florida is like it's you know
Native American and then Spanish like
you know the Spanish came here like in
the 1500s and you know and there's a the
history of it is really interesting
we've got like like I said we got
[__] Spaniards and Pirates and yeah
it's like it's pretty awesome
Mississippi Louisiana parts of Alabama
that's [__] French
France and Indians
Spain too they would kind of blend it
together
there would be [__]
a French town over there and a Spanish
Town over there and an Indian
settlements over there and
you know they're and then they they
don't talk about [__] like
oh man
the [__] um
Apache and what was it the the Apache
and the not not what were the
[__] what was the other one the Apache
and Comanche War went on for over 200
and some years
yeah two Indian tribes the size of
England size of European nations went at
it for [__] over 200 years
like I said I don't remember and maybe
I'm just remembered because like I said
it was a long time ago but I kind of
remember at least at the high school
level and earlier than that too there
was hardly anything about it was from a
very much
english-centric yeah like here come the
settlers here come the the pilgrims or
whatever and it's like and that's when
America started it's like they didn't
talk about like the thousands of years
like of the people here before then or
like what was going on with that or like
or even like what was going on in
Florida yeah it was around in here I
mean like I said I know that they only
have like a limited amount of time and
it's like you know this is a massive
country and it's like you can't
cover everything but I don't know I
thought like I said I think people would
have been more interested if like they
had gone down more rabbit holes
the United States and Canada and Mexico
they just kind of slowly evolved and
emerged from a [__]
Quagmire or a [__]
tribal and ethnic Warfare and things
changing the hands and over and over
again it was all kind of happening at
the same time it's not like
okay here yeah
the pilgrims showed up
and [__] I think his name was John
Smith
like [__] on day four or five India
shows up and speaks perfect English who
just got there from England yeah and it
was Squanto yeah hey yeah I speak
English
[__] he was like what what yeah I
just got here from England [__] I
came back over here on a boat yeah we
have boats too yeah
but we were you know and it was like I
was over there for [__] over a decade
you know they showed me around they
captured me and took me over there and
showed me around and then just let me go
they just captured him as a novelty
which is crazy we met the queen what if
you're just walking down the street and
you saw somebody that's kind of cool
looking you're like you know what I'm
just gonna like [__] and just like
snatch that person and just like take
them home so you can look at them yeah
the Squanto met the Queen of England
yeah and [__] hung out and everything
and then he ended up backing back in the
United States he came back and uh his
whole tribe had been wiped out by plague
yeah while he was gone well he was gone
the Spanish the African story is yeah
yeah so and then then there's all this
kind of weird [__]
oh
weird [__] twist that they put on
history that
somehow you know white people defeated
all these Indians and [__] took all
their land and
no the white man mostly got his ass
kicked by England by Indians
um most of the Indians died out from a
plague before white people even got here
it was basically kind of like when the
white people showed up it was like what
Squanto said it was post-apocalyptic
they had been wiped out by a pandemic so
they were already kind of weakened
the US Army never the U.S army only
fought some Indians and they usually
lost to him
um it was kind of like
weird massacres that would happen every
now and then like that one where the US
Army accidentally massacred a whole
bunch of
Indian Christians
because they thought that they were
rising up
uh to kill the white man which they were
really awaiting a new [__]
savior that was coming they did because
they didn't speak the same language that
was another one I forgot the name of
that one over a hundred people got
killed in that one
um
the Indians were never really defeated
per se a bunch of changing alliances it
was like Europe
what ended up happening is that roads
came and cars and that was the end of
Indians and cowboys and [__] you just
you couldn't Chase Buffalo you're
running through other people's property
you had fences everywhere
land ownership fences and [__] road
systems and trains the Advent of
Technology destroyed all those old
Lifestyles it didn't matter
what your ethnic group was
so many [__] white people married so
many Indians
a lot of them were just absorbed
um
most people carry Native American DNA
most so-called white people
up here
um
white women were notorious for running
off with Indians
um
in the through a lot of the through a
lot of the American history there
weren't enough white women white guys
wanted to marry Indian Brides they
basically wiped out the Mandan because
they married all their women
you know the Mandan Indians just became
white people
so it's just not these simple answers it
was
the [__] went on for [__] centuries
well like I said so I can see how when
you're just trying to give students you
know just a broad outline
um of History
um you know yeah you're gonna have to
simplify some [__] obviously because you
can't cover it all because everything is
like super complicated it would take
like a million years but still I don't
know I still feel like like I said I
don't know
um what the curriculum is like nowadays
but it's like I used to think it was so
funny that they had like a whole class
of American History which like I said
seemed like it was 95 pilgrims and then
um I don't even remember like getting up
to like modern American history I just
remember it being like pretty much all
pilgrims I don't know like maybe I'm
just remembering it wrong and then so we
just had that and then we just had a
another class that was just world
history and like I said it was almost
all Europe like and it was almost a
western Europe yeah I don't remember
learning hardly anything about Eastern
Europe about Africa about I mean you
know other than
um you know okay Egypt and [__] like
that but it's just in Egypt and Greece
and Rome and you learned about that but
it's just kind of like you know nothing
really about Asia like what was going on
in Asia it was like whole swaths of the
world were neglected pretty much yeah
which you know
so I just feel like
you can't have it how can you have just
like one
class that's just world history there's
just too much and it's too much most of
what Americans know in the outside world
know about you American history they got
the [__] from [__] Hollywood and
Hollywood doesn't know history or they
have a slanted view of it same thing
with military power military operations
most Americans don't know [__] about the
militaries everything they do know this
includes the politicians everything they
do know came from Hollywood movies which
are highly inaccurate
like for instance uh
if you were to look at photographs
of the U.S army cavalry
in the 1850s 1860s up to the 1870s most
of them will have bought a Ben Lakota
Indians
yeah
most of the US army cavalry was Lakota
and it's because they joined America
and to protect their homelands they all
joined the U.S Cavalry
and who do you think was patrolling
the [__] Great Planes the same people
that came from here the Lakota
so Lakota wore US army stuff and
uniforms and you can see their yearbooks
and
waving the [__] state flags American
flags unit Flags
and they're definitely Indians
and they love that [__] you know World
War II came they [__] joined up
um
Native American cultures very Macho
culture
for a man to have value in a tribal
Society or any kind of [__] decent
Society you ask me you have to prove
yourself as a fighter and a [__]
Hunter
and you know
Indians weren't allowed to [__] wage
war on each other so they just joined
the US Army
they'll serve with a bunch of them same
thing with Islanders Pacific Islanders
those are all Warrior cultures
you know Maori
[__] Hawaiians micronesians Samoans
those dudes are [__] warlike man
that's a good thing
if you got to channel it properly
Camp guy said we had a weak history
class but a very strong science
chemistry math English and English
composition classes yeah I mean I think
overall and I went to public school but
um I think I got a very good broad
education but I think a lot of that too
was because I was interested and engaged
and I read a lot of stuff outside of
class that I didn't have to but I think
yeah I think probably and I think it's
probably just because it was my favorite
but I really liked um
particularly my high school English
classes you know what I mean not so much
my 10th grade when my 11th grade when I
think was my because that was um that
was European literature so we got to
read uh Beowulf and we got to read like
Shakespeare and we got like we read
Macbeth and
um I'm trying to think what else we read
but we read like a whole bunch of other
like Frankenstein I think we read
Frankenstein
[Music]
some other [__] so you know what I mean
so I I liked that a lot
but I was always kind of more like an
English
lit person
but I like science classes too
I didn't like I I wasn't a big fan of
chemistry though which is weird because
when I was a kid I was real into that
like my parents bought me a chemistry
set and holy [__] me and my brothers
used to play with that all the time
we're trying to make bombs that's what
we're trying to do but you know what I
mean we never succeeded
um but we did some other cool [__] with
it
but then when I
went to the chemistry class it's like
like I said they just it depends on the
teacher I guess too but it's like they
just kind of made it boring
I kind of liked more biology type stuff
uh
and all that
I remember being in junior high we had
this teacher that
I can't remember what kind of science it
was it was like I guess it was just like
General physical science or whatever but
he was one of those
um
what do you call them Storm Chasers so
he was so so he did kind of like hijack
all of the curriculum to like talk about
hurricanes and tornadoes and stuff
because he was like super into that like
he had like the um the pickup truck that
had all the weather [__] on it and so
like every time there was like a
hurricane or a tornado he would like
drive out in the middle of it
I was listening to something the other
day that was um I guess it was kind of
like a famous case but I can't remember
what their names are now but um where
there was like some
some of those Storm Chasers who I guess
I don't remember if they had a YouTube
channel or no it wasn't a YouTube
channel they had a show in like
Discovery or something like that and
they I think it was called Storm Chasers
maybe and they were like kind of famous
and they actually died doing that [__]
like they you know they were out in like
a [__] tornado they were watching a
tornado and it turned right toward him
and it was a massive [__] F6
[__] or something like that and
they they said we're pretty much like
they're all like they can hear them
because it was audio they found the
their audio equipment like afterward and
yeah they're just basically uh we're
gonna die and then like and then they
found him later like just scattered
[__] everywhere like it was pretty
horrible but yeah I was like listening
to that the other day so that was a
little depressing
yeah Camp guy said I never read much
more than half a page of his of a
history book in high school and skimmed
most of the rest
yeah they're just I mean I don't know
I've I've always felt like maybe
especially maybe with junior high
students or students are a little bit
younger I think you should play up
um the gruesome [__] because kids love
that [__] play up to gruesome [__] play
up like Wars and battles and people
getting beheaded and [__] like that
because I used to love that [__] kids
love that [__] but it says India's
washed didn't it yeah
[__]
that's another thing man is that uh
what a lot of people when they think of
the Native Americans they think of
something they saw in a Hollywood movie
and and that's not accurate they're
being they're being portrayed as if they
were primitive and that they were kind
of stone age
and that they were coming face to face
with like a uh
[__] industrial civilization that was
just [__] them up
no no not at all whatever white whatever
white people had
at any given time pretty much Indians
had it too
we had horses they had horses we had
guns they had guns we had steel they had
steel it's just
they tended to to want different things
like
they liked their britches better because
they were they were better for horseback
but they liked jackets they wore those
um they liked guns lever action guns
when they arrived
but before the Advent of the metallic
cartridge Indians didn't want guns that
was like a shitty weapon for for the
Indian lifestyle you couldn't get powder
and the powder would have gotten wet and
it's the first time it rained
if it was a match lock it was worthless
a [__] flintlocks were you still
needed that powder
and the reload time was a long time the
bow was a lot better weapon than a than
a primitive
muzzleloading rifle with [__] black
powder you know it just
that you couldn't use that for combat
you might be able to use it for hunting
but a lot of Indians that hunting was
kind of ritual it was something you did
from horseback you ran up on a buffalo
and you speared it or you shot it with
arrows and chased it and it was kind of
like a religious event shooting it was
kind of like they wouldn't have dug that
that had been like a real [__] way of
doing it
because it was you're proven you know
what a good Hunter you were
so Indians didn't want any guns because
they were inferior they didn't want them
until the metallic cartridge came out
it's like call us when they're good yeah
when they got that then
then they [__] started using them and
they were good with them
um
most of the time if
if one of those groups came in contact
with the US Army and conflict the U.S
army
the Indians usually kicked the Army's
ass
most of the time the US Army used a
falling block
single shot 45-70 carbine
now man the Indians were using lever
action [__] Winchester's when they
could get them lever action carbines
which unless these could carry [__]
12 13 Rounds and [__] high capacity
that was like an AK-47 at the time
and they fought from Ambush they fought
like reasonable people you know
US Army was still trying to do [__] like
Skirmish lines a lot of times or well
Cavalry combat not not so much but
Indians were kind of better better
Fighters
and they grew up doing that kind of
stuff
a lot of the US Army guys are kind of
drafted or joined up from from out east
they were kind of city boys they were
kind of soft compared to Indians
the Indians [__] had better [__] most
of the time and if we if they if we had
something that they didn't have they'd
just buy it they had money people think
that Indians didn't have money no
Indians had money
they traded you know traded and traded
with money and got their hands on things
and uh the only difference is their
lifestyle and they had their own little
um Nations you know kind of like back in
Europe it would have been the Franks and
the Saxons and you know the Geeks and
the you know it was like that
and uh what got them
was that their lifestyle became
unsustainable technology
as soon as you started having property
rights and fences just steamrolled
everything yeah you can you can't run
around chasing the Buffalo anymore
and uh
the Western economy took over
you had to get a job
you had to [__] pay rent
that changed everything
you know you could buy land but you then
you had to pay your you had to pay your
mortgage
now some Indians didn't want to become
American citizens so they ended up on
those reservations
which that was their own land now they
could have Tribal councils and [__] and
then the problem is a lot of
reservations were in areas where there's
no economy
you know so they were poor
as a when a young guy was born there if
he wanted to do anything he wasn't going
to be able to do anything on the
reservation that joined the US Army
so that's why I have a lot of them ended
up in the Army but they didn't really go
back
get out of the army they just marry some
white girl living in a city like anybody
else
they're popular Indians are popular here
they're not
some kind of oppressed
minority that hated or anything there's
nothing like that no [__]
me and Jen are friends with a real
Indian
princess
like Atari her dad [__] works for
Indian Affairs and everything and she's
a pug rocker
Camp guy said we had a chemistry teacher
in eighth grade that poured one whole
cup of sugar into a 2 000 milliliter
Erlenmeyer flask it created a giant
black carbon turd that poured out lots
of smoke and we had to evacuate the
flask had about 500 milliliters of
sulfuric acid in it the teacher claimed
he had done that experiment before but
he looked pretty surprised when that
acid started reacting with it
I think I see that as a similar reaction
to that I'm sure that was like really
entertaining Cal says Horrible Histories
is a great book series for kids those
are great I've seen like some of those
uh my son loved it he's a major history
buff because I taught him all about all
the stuff you never learned in school
yeah see I think that's the kind of the
way especially boys but I mean I was
kind of into gruesome [__] too when I
was a kid a lot of kids are so I think
that if you kind of you know you don't
have to go too over the top if they're
like little kids but
kids are like fascinated by
gross [__] like creepy [__] yeah so if
you kind of focus on that kind of stuff
you're gonna get them a lot more engaged
in it for sure because I mean I was when
I was a kid I always wanted to hear
about like all the [__] you know
kings and queens being beheaded and all
that kind of stuff that was what I found
interesting
Ben said it's talking about um he said I
met the hygiene differences to Europeans
Europeans were Whigs because their hair
fell out from parasites they powdered
their faces because of all the disease
and dirt perfume to mask Bo yeah they
were a little dirty and the um and the
cities were uh cesspits pretty much
because they hadn't really figured out
um sanitation the other great degree
here in the new world though now the the
Europeans that came here weren't the
same breed they weren't really wearing a
lot of wigs and wearing a lot of Stuffy
clothes they maybe when they first got
off the boat
but very quickly that shit's too
impractical here especially in the South
that's [__] far too hot
uh yeah they did wear jackets and [__]
1800s looking type stuff
but it wasn't as bad as it was up in
Europe it was too hot
too hot
and um
wigs and makeup
according to the writings of the 1700s
was seen as a European things uh
Americans frowned on that they saw that
as something from the aristocracy really
a feet and snotty and
um they didn't even like to wear colors
uh
Americans of the 1700s evidently like to
wear black and white they thought that
was a very serious color
and it probably came from having a
religious backgrounds too
but like uh
when Ben Franklin went to
France he had to go out of his way to
buy colored clothes like Browns and
Golds and reds and stuff because he had
mostly brown and black and white white
shirts with brown and black
jackets and pants and [__]
because you didn't want us to be seen as
like a clown
you wanted to see this like serious and
with the austere yeah that you weren't
jaded they had good morals you know you
could trust you were trustworthy you
know that was that was the thinking
which like I said I get it
um but on the other side of that coin
a lot of the early American settlers
were real sticks in the mud gonna say
depending on where you were talking
about that's true they weren't all the
same no yeah yeah I know I'm just saying
that
because of the American history class
that I had that focused a lot on the
pilgrims so we read like a lot of their
writings and stuff and I was just kind
of like God these people sound [__]
they were religious fundamentalists oh
yeah
yeah the Europeans were like we don't
want you or get out yeah
they didn't like European ways they saw
him as corrupt
get this is a great story Gadget says we
found a long forgotten tampon stuck to
the ceiling of our chemistry class draw
your own conclusions but the janitor
used a chisel to remove it
I'm assuming it was like a used one
gross so some chick just said she's
gonna yank it out
that's what I was the first thing I
thought she acts it out and flings it up
on the [__] ceiling that's [__]
nasty
oh man
yet it obviously was soaked in water
before being launched at the ceiling
gross Ben says it was a long-running
kids science show called The Curiosity
show the host said every week they got
hundreds of letters asking about the
science behind boogers farts and Pooh
yeah see that's what I mean kids love
gross [__]
that's why that's why I like a lot of
museums and stuff like that if they have
like a kid section they always have like
a booger fart thing and they always have
like a bug Zoo like with spiders and
roaches and [__] like that because kids
love that kind of [__] they love that
kind of [__]
if you engage them like that like you
can teach them all kind of stuff
yeah Tammy points out in the 70s
white doctors would sterilize Indian
girls after they gave birth to their
first kid so they wouldn't have any more
Indians were still treated as other oh
yeah big time Big Time it probably
depends on where it was you were talking
about
I never heard of that one
yeah it's going on yeah Tammy said my
husband had Cherokee great grandmothers
on both sides of his family they went
through a lot yeah yeah it you have to
remember that there was a bunch of
eugenics that was happening in the in
the 1900s he started I think in the 20s
in the United States
it wasn't just Indians it was white
people too if you went to jail they'd
sterilize you
well in anyone that had like um yeah
mental retardation if there was anything
any hint of inbreeding in your family
they'd sterilize the whole [__]
family
um
they were trying and they were there
were pockets of
in rural areas of [__] in inbred
towns you know and uh yeah you had state
governments
or sometimes ngos going in there
uh like a Margaret Sanger type [__]
operations going down there trying to
remove human weeds is what basically
what they considered them
and you know they wouldn't do it
forcibly per se they go in there and
they would say hey
here's 200 if you take this 200 you can
do quick operation and it'll keep the
size of your family down they didn't
really explain it totally what it was
but they would bait them in with money
and gifts and stuff and they'd do it
and who knows it might have it
definitely I think improved certain
certain areas because uh some people
really [__] up they got they had the
photographic evidence I mean you know
you some of these people
in these rural areas they looked at them
they're definitely inbred
and the [__] IQs were [__] rock
bottom
I mean they had been in those pockets
without any really proper roads going in
and out of them for generations and it
might only be like three families in
that [__] area right there
you know and there's three or four
generations of people in there and it's
only two families you know so hey
something's up yeah Camp guy said that
dude on the soft white underbelly
Channel found an inbred Appalachian
Family he goes and films currently
living in a Shack in the woods oh yeah
I've seen that family one of the members
just barks like a dog that [__]
scared the [__] out of me they just
drool
yeah terrible
yeah I mean
what kind of life is that really I mean
I mean that
it's like I kind of want to see that
like because you've told me about that
before yeah I kind of don't want to
think so but
the kind of stuff is also happening on
those reservations there weren't there
wasn't enough people in those
reservations for a proper breeding
population
depends on which as I've said they're
not all the same you know what I mean
some of those reservations were bigger
or nicer or in better areas other ones
were just small
totally isolated so then you end up with
a situation like Appalachia there isn't
enough breeding population there
you know and it gets can get it can go
sideways
uh yeah big time yeah you can't just
reuse the same jeans almost over and
over again right
that always goes wrong uh Cal said I
heard the Amish are super inbred now and
the kids are being born with all sorts
of genetic problems
I've seen a lot of them know they look
real healthy I guess like I said it's
anything else it depends on where you're
talking about the Amish aren't in one
place well and I had heard that like in
some Amish communities like a lot of the
young people are leaving obviously
because the life is too strict it's
austere
for them and they don't like it which
you know I can't blame them I wouldn't
want to like live like that but
you know so yeah there's they're gonna
be like fewer
jeans to go around you have to have a
viable breeding population
and I don't remember what the numbers
were
yeah I think you need to have several
hundred people
and they can't be related
and that's sustainable
you know or at least most of them can't
be related
you know because there's gonna be
families and several hundred people but
you needed viable breeding population
yeah they have to be genetically diverse
you have to mix [__] up yeah you got to
make [__] up you won't have
uh you won't have any [__] genetic
Health there's a lot of people that
don't understand like
um
[__] race mixing they have a [__]
weird idea about genetic weight
basically all Races of people that exist
today if they've existed for any amount
of time have taken Outsiders into them
all right of people from other races
black people Asian people whatever
it's just that the intake was very slow
so it didn't really racially change them
they looked the same if you were to do a
genetic test on them they'd probably be
carrying genes from Africa or Asia
and that's good that actually promotes
the health of that population doesn't
change their race though it keeps
they're still say like you could do that
to the laplanders they would still be
laplanders
it's just that they'd be a little
healthier than they would if you didn't
do that because
what do they call it there was a term
that they called it
there's something the old term was
called hybrid vigor
bringing in outside genes into any
population is beneficial because the
good stuff tends to rise to the top
and the bad genes tend to be erased by
the influx of new better genes so you
have less problems like
diabetes and
just other things you know
if I can
genetic Health the looks start to get
better
um it's just better
all humans are related anyway
it's just like anything else and it
wasn't really uh that long ago yeah that
we were like a very small bottleneck
right
it's fine
yeah Ben said you really should do lost
German slave girl yeah I have been
putting that in the poll because I read
that book like a few years ago and it
was
that about
well it was kind of about it was about
one specific person but it was kind of
about the whole like indentured
servitude yeah thing of like you know
people being brought over yeah
yeah there were Irish slaves yeah
you don't hear much about it and then
even the indentured servitude some of
the stuff that was going on in brothels
those contracts that those girls were
under that kind of slavery well it is in
Romans in Roman times they would have
considered that slavery yeah because you
could do that at Rome you could sell
yourself as a slave to pay off a debt
for a certain amount of time that's kind
of what those girls were doing
but worse really yeah
um
yeah
I would not have liked to live back then
ah
a lot of people didn't live long
especially in the west that's what I'm
saying it's just like
people piss and moan about us like [__]
being hard now but it's like yeah no
thanks go back 100 years 200 years yeah
uh no
that'd have just been fun a lot of
people don't realize
that those houses didn't have running
water in them
and that actually can be is
recently like in the 30s in the 20s in
the United States there were still
houses that didn't have running water it
had outhouses
you went outside to go take a [__] in an
outhouse
if you lived in an urban environment
before the Advent of [__] running
water but you're still 1800s
you shot in a [__] pot and put a lid
on it and slide it underneath your bed a
chamber pot
which I can't imagine so
you got to imagine this it was
summertime in these big cities those
places much ecstatic to high heaven yeah
and they probably didn't notice it but
if you went to a time machine you'd
probably be like God damn this place is
[__] rank because they didn't all
those some people back then did complain
about it but yeah so because there was
no modern septic system there was no way
of flushing the [__] out of that damn
City it was just sitting in there and
they were just throwing it out no
[__]
horse and buggy come and pick it up in
the morning take it out with the garbage
if it did I mean there were some places
where even garbage service wasn't
reliable City living was [__]
horrible up until the 1900s really
[__] I wouldn't live in a city in the
1800s [__] crazy yeah
too dirty
yeah event trust the food
yeah I mean you really couldn't trust
the food until probably after the second
world war yeah
because that's kind of one that's when
all the that's kind of and when all the
regulations and stuff came in it's like
before that yeah they really didn't have
any uh there was actually no legal
prescription to tell you what was in any
of the [__] yeah they could just put
anything in there the US Army was
actually like the gateway to [__]
sanitation and good food
um
their their military rations
that what I'm talking about mainly is
Spam so spam and canned cheese which is
like cheese whiz
not cheese whiz
what do you call it Velveeta like a
Velveeta cheese it came in a can those
two products right there were just
change the world
yeah
you could trust that you would not get
sick by those and it was protein whey
protein for the cheese and then animal
protein and spam is not low quality meat
it's just pork shoulder and it's cooked
in the can and brine it's too salty
but they didn't know back then they
wanted to be better safe than sorry they
make that [__] real salty to
keep any bacteria from forming
they could have done that job with a
quarter of that salt it still would have
worked but you can get low sodium spam
now you can get different flavors I like
spam
um because it's the ultimate MRE it's
all meat
it's [__] in an indestructible
package you can carry it it's light
um
you can eat it Frozen
or or you can cook it but in an
emergency you can slice it and eat it
Frozen
and it tastes good Frozen and having
eaten Frozen MREs and [__]
that's the acid test a lot of the foods
that you eat taste good hot as soon as
that thing's cold or frozen it tastes
like [__]
um
that was a good thing when I was in the
armies that every one of those MREs
tasted good Frozen
ham slice it would sit there to crackle
in your [__] and be chewing and you
go okay
yeah this is what Eskimos are when
they're eating whale
you know Frozen whale yeah this is what
yeah it's good you know
um
just even frozen tuna noodles was good
and um it was just something about this
the seasoning or the lack of seasoning I
don't know what it is I got some of
those you know those uh
Dinty Moore
meals
remember those little [__] meals yeah
like that they're good hot eat one of
those when it's not warmed up it's
terrible
and they were actually in running uh in
a military to get a military contract to
become an MRE now see that's why one of
the reasons why they would have failed
because that [__] tastes terrible cold
yeah
I gotta tell you one thing that I take
to work with me sometimes
um that it's just it's shelf stable it
doesn't have to be refrigerated
and you don't have to heat it up
um I think bumblebee makes them
and they're called quick catch and it's
just a little bowl It's 190 calories
it's got tuna chickpeas and little
um like rotini pasta and tomatoes I
think isn't it and it's actually really
good like for that kind of thing and I
just eat it like room temperature I
don't heat it up or nothing you can if
you want but I don't
um and it's just good like that
you know yeah and it's just and it's a
good and it's like a perfect it's like a
snack portion like I said it's like 190
calories but that's usually what I eat
for lunches or something like that
um Zach says show idea Infamous computer
viruses or scams
you know that actually might be
interesting I don't think I ever thought
of doing a show like that but that
actually might be it might be good Angie
says he loves spam I like spam too you
just kind of cook spam I don't love it
but slice it thin and you fry it
it's good fried like if you mix it with
scrambled eggs or something yeah and
then I make something like an egg like
like an eggs benedict or a [__] Egg
McMuffin yeah you can do that with it
yeah you've toast a couple muffins or
toast and then fried eggs cheese put
spam on it put it in between two pieces
of bread it's good on naan like that
eggs cheese spam on naan toasted really
good
if you want to put a little bit of hot
sauce on it that that'll work or hot
sauce and [__] grape jelly and grape
jelly and the salt mixes together on
it's kind of like glazing on a ham
that's good
then they had all the flavored spams
they're real good like they have a
chorizo flavor which is like a Mexican
sausage that's good
jalapenos good the turkey's all right
um
I'd mostly like the just the low sodium
the regular low sodium
and in World War II that was uh they'd
get like two or three of those cans a
day that's what they lived on
and they'd eat every they'd eat that
whole [__] spam Block in one setting
and uh
I think it's about 1200 calories but
it's all protein I think it's no it
might be not may not be that much
I'd have to look I think I think it
might be eight 900 calories
but it's all protein sounds about right
because it's kind of it's I mean it's
not big but it's kind of dense yeah like
it's a lot of meat
and the can
is indestructible so it's good packaging
you can put it in a backpack or rucksack
and crush it and throw it up on throw it
into a huge pile on the back of trucks
or do whatever you want once everybody
take some camping yeah and uh same thing
with the new cans of tuna they have a
pull top on them the pull ring
you can have
a regular can and just use a P-38 which
is a can opener you can use that but
pull ring is a lot easier
another one that you can use
is uh the uh
can of [__] corned beef hash that
that's
a good ration
they used to give us that when they're
in the Army just it was in a bag
another one is a beanie weeny and it's
not real high in protein though but it's
a good nice break and they come in kind
of small cabs
another one I found was uh
can of uh tamales
with a pull ring on the top of it
they're good and you can eat them cold
they come wrapped in wax paper
it's pretty good the Hormel made him see
that's the thing I feel like there's a
lot of like canned food that you could
you know ostensibly take with you like
when you were camping or out in the
field or whatever but it's like how much
of that like tastes good cold or room
temperature and like probably not much
right not much of it and uh the military
standard was MRE meal ready to eat that
means you can just eat it just like it
is at any temperature
so that's the acid test because
technically spam
you can eat it Frozen
it doesn't quite taste as good but it's
been fickle yeah right it was ready to
eat most guys cooked it though
Tammy said 630 calories it's a classic
can of spam okay that's not bad
three of those a day is fine and it's
all protein so that's good yeah I mean
if you're if you're going uh doing like
burning a lot of calories yeah yeah and
in an emergency you could probably get
away with one can a day
yeah I mean that's not ideal obviously
but in an emergency one yeah
let's see Karen Lee says hi late but I
made it yeah I'm actually surprised at
like how late it is already yeah it's
late I mean it's not late late it's 9 30
but it's like right you know it's Friday
night so we're not going anyplace I
wouldn't mind another drink actually
okay
just
please
because we're not going any place
yeah it took me a really long time
because
the place where I work only for one more
week
um they have a refrigerator but it's
like it's always full and it's just kind
of like I don't know I just don't want
to deal with it
you know what I mean because I'm just
like that I just I'm just like I don't
want to [__] deal with it I don't
want to deal with like microwaving [__]
because there there's no there's a
little kitchen but there's not a break
room there's like nowhere inside to like
sit and eat
um you know there's like a picnic table
outside but that's it so I usually just
kind of like sit in my car and like
watch YouTube or read a novel or
something
so I was like well I want something that
doesn't have to be refrigerated that I
can just
keep in a bag like in my like by my desk
or whatever and then I can just go out
to the car and eat and not have to heat
it up or anything so it took a long time
to get to
but I found that the best ones
um are just these little
tuna bowls
because they can you don't have to heat
them up you can if you want but they're
fine like room temperature they taste
totally fine the the best one like I
said is the um I think it's
I guess it's Mediterranean I think it's
called Mediterranean and it's just you
know tuna a little bit of rotini
chickpeas
and I think it's tomatoes and like some
other spices and stuff but that's like
really good they have some other flavors
too they have like a Teriyaki one which
is pretty good it's not as good as the
Mediterranean one though and then Dollar
General actually makes two of its own
brand of tuna Bowls one of them is fried
rice and one of them is Mexican both of
those are okay too and they both have
tuna in them
but the Mexican one and I know this is
gonna make me sound like super white but
um the Mexican one is like too hot for
me I can't I used to be able to eat hot
food
um but the older I get I found that it's
um
I can't really do it anymore it's
getting to a point where it's just
oh yeah and then the other one the fried
rice one is okay but it's kind of bland
so honestly my favorite one that I and I
usually order them like in big six packs
from Amazon because it's cheaper is the
Mediterranean tuna one all right
I've got some stuff here that I picked
up this is my bug out stuff Zach says
but Jenny you are super white yes I'm
aware of that
this was cheap as hell Clover got this
at a dollar store chili with beans
yeah see that's the Dollar General brand
yeah and that was about I think that was
a dollar
and I tried it it's good
you could pour this over a bag of Fritos
or you can pour this over the top of a
cooked Ramen
and make something out of that I mean
anything like I love ramen so anything
you pour in Robin's gonna it doesn't
have a pull ring
tamales
the protein was
pretty good the calories are good it was
only like a dollar or something
I said I like Clif bars the mega ones
have like 20 grams of protein yeah those
are pretty good actually I've had some
of those now
this is stuff more like an MRE because
it comes in a metallic bag
tuna Creations yeah see I like those all
different kind of flavors of these
I got I don't remember what that flavor
was I had the other day but it was good
you could put that in a butt pack or uh
something just something you would carry
on you I mean I just you can do other
things with that but honestly I just
took that to work with me and just ate
it out of the pouch with a spoon a slice
of spam
oh I didn't even know they made those
look how cute that is the only thing is
is that it's a little baby fan it's a
baby span
it's not really economical this is about
a dollar something
all right for four dollars you can get a
can which is about eight times this
but you're buying it for the packaging
yeah I mean that's handy right handy
Packaging
do cow refried beans in a bag
there you go all right I got this see
what a time to be alive got this at the
South America store
all right the South American Market over
there across the street from Starbucks
it's good too just rip the top of it and
you can squeeze it out right into your
mouth
yeah
I could just see Tom like [__] main
lighting yeah refried beef you can get
these at Dollar Store Velveeta cheese in
a bag
that's the jalapeno flavor and I see I
might I might I might squeeze that right
into my mouth and you're like what would
you want that for you can put it in with
a Ramen yeah you can put it on a refried
beans this is whey protein you can dip
crackers in it yeah so this is
equivalent to a meat it's a protein
okay it's only like a dollar I mean it's
not cheese obviously it's a cheese like
product and you can get fancy
Indian food
vegetable korma I haven't had it cold
but hot this is really good
okay
yeah those are pretty good yeah honestly
one of my most favorite ones it actually
comes in like a little box like that
and it's peanut noodles yeah like Thai
peanut noodles oh my God they're
delicious vegetarian tikka masala I
don't buy it anymore though because it's
like 800 calories now see what you can
put this you can put spam in this
pre-cook this man put in there so you
can have meat in it it's not high in
protein this is the only problem with it
but it's good in flavor it's got
calories
basma Indian basmati rice pre-cooked
see Tom has like really into this he has
like a whole pile of like yeah he's
always like investigating new I would
have loved this in the Army yeah see
they probably have much better [__] yeah
um
Ben says on Cadet camp we subsisted on
spam and dry biscuits one guy said the
only way he could take a crap was to put
his foot on the end of the turd and
stand up
oh man
Zach said I wonder how many times
refried beans have been used his fake
[__] in a movie see I was when I was
growing up
um you know we ate Mexican food quite a
bit
but I was always really grossed out like
but I couldn't get past the appearance
of refried beans so it's just like I
never ate them but then like when I got
older I was like oh wow these are
actually really good I was actually I
wasn't
um I don't think I'd go so far to say it
was a super picky eater when I was a kid
but there was a lot of stuff that I was
just kind of like oh that looks gross or
ooh that smells gross or something like
that and then I just wouldn't eat it so
I didn't really start like until I was
in my late teens or 20s like I didn't
really start actually eating a lot of
regular food and the thing about it was
that because I grew up in the South like
we just kind of ate
you know Cracker Barrel type stuff you
know what I mean mostly
so we didn't have like a lot of
variety I don't even think I even ate
Indian food until I was in my 20s you
know what I mean or any or anything like
that
uh hey Victor Rich says hey I made it uh
yeah I mean we've been on for a while
but we're not that drunk yet but
Zach says uh I'm still a picky eater
I've never liked onions or tomatoes if I
get a burger they come off
um
it's we you know what's weird is I
always liked onions I've always liked
onions as a kid I can't eat them raw
anymore because again it just gives me
like immediate heartburn so if so if I
have like a burger they have to be I
like them on there but they have to be
cooked I can't eat them raw
anymore I used to like them raw but I
can't eat them like that anymore but
when I was a kid man I used to hate
Tomatoes I hated tomatoes and I hated
mushrooms and I don't know why exactly
they just like made me ill I don't know
if it was just kind of like the look of
them or the texture or what it was and
it's crazy because now like those are
legit like two of my favorite foods like
I'll actually we go to the the Chinese
buffet
and they have just like a big pot of
like you know sauteed mushrooms I'll
just have like a whole [__] pile of
those yeah it's like I'll just eat them
all by themselves and then I'll go over
and get like the little salad that they
have with raw tomatoes and cucumbers and
I'll just like eat a bunch of that
but it's just funny
um
you know it so I I don't know I I just
feel like I was kind of and it's kind of
I think we've talked about this before
but when I was a little kid I was
absolutely absolutely disgusted by peas
like I couldn't even stand the sight of
them like just the sight of them made me
want to gag it's the weirdest thing like
I didn't have a visceral reaction like
that to pretty much any other food there
was food that I didn't really like or
care for but Peas I was just like the
second I saw them I was like you know
what I mean I was just like I couldn't
stand the look of them I couldn't stand
the smell of them it's ridiculous well I
mean it was just a food aversion I mean
everybody has something like I broke her
that
he eventually did yeah it took a while
it took a while yeah what I did is I
made a [__] delicious pea soup yeah
split pea soup with big chunks of ham in
it yeah and [__]
um
it even had uh it had ham
carrots
it even had a little bit of them clove
remember it was good it's almost like
it's like a
almost like a Christmas split pea soup I
think that's where I think the [__]
ham was a Christmas ham I think it was
actually because I think it a little bit
after Christmas
and um you didn't see any peas
see it was all Blended yeah it's just a
green soup and she's like oh this is
great
you can have an inversion to it as soon
as you train now this is great now I
honestly like I still won't because when
I was growing up I mean they would just
do like a bowl of peas which was like a
canned yeah and like just as a side I
still don't think I would just eat peas
just on their own but um but pea soup is
good and there's a peas in a lot of
Indian food yeah and I'll eat them in
that yeah
um and they don't bother me but yeah so
it's just like I still don't want just
like a pile of them by itself because
it's like not my favorite thing
but yeah we got to go back and uh go to
the Indian buffet too
I was thinking about that we went like a
month or two ago and I was like man I
forgot how good this place was it don't
they don't have it's it's all you can
eat buffet they don't have a huge amount
of things they use only just like
probably like a dozen or it's enough 15
20 things but yeah it's like they
usually have really good they have
different [__] like every time you go
but they usually have
um man they had something in there when
they didn't have it last time but they
had it like the time before and it was
like tikka masala like that taste but it
was paneer yeah and man that I ate a
whole bunch of that yeah that [__] was
good their paneer dishes are always like
really good I love paneer I don't know
what it is about it I just really like
the texture of it it's very mild but
I just really like stuff with uh yeah
Victor said peas are gross peas are not
gross man [__] stop the [__] like I
said it's just a it's a weird odd food
it is yeah but it's just it's no weirder
than black eyed peas or no weirder than
lima beans it's just a different version
of those I don't love lima beans you
like butter beans
yeah they're all right
for you in the UK or maybe up north you
know what a butter bean is it's like a
lima bean it's a big bean it's flat
and um
you cook them in the South usually serve
it with ham over rice
yeah my grandma used to make that all
the time and they're they're they're
yellow they're yellow like a yellow lima
bean but it's bigger and it's flatter
and they get very soft and tender melt
in your mouth like butter and they're
kind of yellow like butter
and they make a yellow gravy
it's really good it's really good
it's just you know not my seasoning salt
and pepper
did Victor said peas made me gay
all kinds of [__] made you gay over the
years Man by the way he said it made you
gay we're keeping him company on his
two-hour drive so we have to stay online
asked for yesterday [__] just goes so
what are you guys into today well we
like to go to clubs this and that and
what about you you know he's like oh I'm
open and he's like okay and then me and
Jenny started ignoring him again we're
talking to each other and he goes
strap-on fun
[Laughter]
I said yeah we got one here come on over
we'll run you through
one of these days whenever they come at
me with that man Mason wonder if it's
one of y'all
yeah it was kind of a slow night last
night we weren't we were only on for
like an hour and a half yeah and we
didn't even get we didn't even get any
like private shows or anything like that
we got tips just tips from plants and
titties and doing crazy [__] but yeah
and [__] like that but we didn't get it
we didn't have to do anything like super
hardcore yeah there just wasn't any
traffic
yeah hardly anybody and it's like I
think that was the longest time that
we've been without anybody coming in the
room yeah you've sat there for 10
minutes and nobody come in the room yeah
which is that's very unusual but like I
said maybe it was just one of those
times you know what I mean because it's
slower uh
mornings and afternoons the best well
that's what I'm telling you that's why
you know I'm taking the leap and we're
gonna I'm gonna start doing it full time
so we can do it in the morning and
afternoon because it's like plus your
energy is up yeah that's what I mean
like coming like coming home and doing
it at night it's just like look I just
got home from work I've been up since
five in the morning it's like you know I
want to do it it's fun but it's just
kind of like man I can only sound for
like an hour and a half because I gotta
take a shower and go to bed you know
what I mean yeah because I got to get up
at five in the morning kind of where
everybody's we're both kind of worn out
yeah and we're doing [__] too right it's
like yeah it's like it's the end of the
day we get up around the same time right
so that's the thing I gotta work on a
bike this weekend yeah that's right yeah
I gotta put that new throw out bearing
well I mean we'll have a million things
to do I have a couple I gotta do a
couple of videos I've already got them
all set up I just gotta like record them
real quick and um I don't know we could
stream we could go I can't believe I
[__] ran over a nail I can't believe
that either but it happens yeah it
happens
uh Zach says I also don't like celery
because why is food enjoyable when it's
actively exhausting to chew through
Zach I used to really I
it is really good with peanut butter on
it and I actually like celery
um I like celery salt a lot yeah but um
I actually like celery when you cut it
up really small and you put it in like
crab salad or something like that
because it gives it like that texture I
like that
um and then Zach's the same with apples
to an extent see I love apples I'm not a
big fan of just eating now green apples
are good for pie okay because you're
always gonna make a pie with green
caramel dip well yeah no that's good
yeah yeah but if I'm just gonna eat an
apple like on the way to work or
whatever it's gotta be like a like a red
one get fat as [__] eating green apples
and caramel dip oh cool that damn
caramel it is good though yeah yeah see
the green apple they're so tart that
like sweet stuff that's why people use
green apples for for pies you don't use
red apples or pies it's not the same and
the texture is not the same yeah because
Zach says I love apple flavored things
but eating actual apples is just kind of
a chore yeah I get it
yeah Ben said I love all Indian food but
Tandoori meat dishes are incredible
yeah I mean like I said I think I only
really got into Indian food much later
like when you started making it like I
had eaten it before but I didn't know a
lot about it until we started until you
started making it and um
yeah it's like I don't I don't know if I
would necessarily categorize that as my
favorite Cuisine but I don't know maybe
I would
what's that Indian food
hard to say it's easy to adapt to Indian
food yeah it's it's easy to fall for
that it's got a great flavor profile it
does yeah it's very manly
and but women like it too it's it's it's
got a foot mentally yes it was just like
the redneck but then it was down there
[__] eating that [__] with this whole
it was a whole lawn crew there because
man this is some [__] manly [__] here
this is good because it's like chilly
but better and that redneck was tearing
that [__] up and half of his lawn crew
were black guys and they go yeah it is
it is good they liked it
and um because that's not a southern
thing but yeah I think there's still
like some contingent of older people and
like working class kind of rednecky
people that are just kind of like Indian
food what's that like it's weird I don't
like foreign food they don't like
foreign food yeah but no those dudes uh
they they saw the greatness they were
like oh yeah this shit's good how can
you not like Indian food well he can't
he called it I heard him say he goes
it's like chili yeah but it's better the
uh yeah that's
well I guess I mean chill it has very
similar like it has a similar flavor
profile I'm pretty sure chili is
Indian
I think it might be I mean it's very
similar cumin and chili powder yeah it's
very similar that's the base and you're
cooking meat in it and real Texas Chili
well they say when it's over isn't a
chili it's from Texas basically
and real Texans will tell you beans
don't belong in that it's just just meat
like a meat stew I've always heard it's
Indian
but I always thought they were talking
about American Indians it might be
Indian and Indian like actual Indian
yeah
because there was
there was a knowledge of India and
spices from India going back centuries
yeah that might be what they're talking
about yeah I don't know
because I kind of feel like every
culture has a dish like that that's just
kind of like a meat stew yeah sort of
it's basically Curry
yeah Curry I mean chili is basically
it's just a different
it's a different
ratio yeah it's the same spices pretty
much it's just a different reason yeah
it's the same method basically yeah and
the thing about Indian food like and
this isn't true like across the board
but a lot of the most famous Indian
dishes that everybody knows about around
the world once you kind of know how to
make one of them you can make most of
the other ones because the because the
yeah the the the
um the way that you make it is like
pretty similar it's just the meat's
different the spice ratios ratios are
different and stuff like that but I mean
honestly like I said I love anything
with paneer in it I love
butter chicken I love I mean butter
chicken is so [__] good
um and the um what's that one you make
all the time that uh with the um yeah
stock paneer yeah
you can put chicken in it too yeah or
you can call it Pollock paneer yeah SOG
Pollock yeah it's basically you take a
[__] ton of spinach Blanchette
Blanchette drain it yeah and then puts
put chicken broth in it
and then blend it
put cream
and it's got cumin seeds and onion and
and sauteed onions and stuff in it and
then you put fried paneer or fried
chicken in it you know cubes of chicken
and there it is cream and it just has a
really nice yeah flavor profile and it's
mild you know I mean that's the nice
thing about Indian food you can make it
hot if you want but you can make it mild
also yeah you can kind of and here's the
thing because I got that Garden going
you don't need
spinach you can use sweet potato greens
that's what we have that's what I use
and they're indistinguishable
because he just put some of those in my
salad just now yeah like when I got home
yeah it tastes like baby spinach yeah it
is pretty much what it tastes like
Tammy says apples with cookie butter
that's right cookie butter yes did you
send me did she say I think that what
didn't it wasn't it you Tammy that sent
us that jar of cookie butter yeah it was
good man it was good yeah you can send
cookie buttery
I don't even know what you got that I
haven't seen cookie butter around it's
in the story yeah you can get it I think
it's over by over by the Nutella
it's just like it's those
what are those cookies that they used to
give you like on Long airplane flights
those kind of they're not shortbread but
they're
they're almost like this British
biscuits you know what I mean yeah
which little there's little vanilla
cookies
or uh they're not vanilla they're kind
of well not really they're like those
little teak coffee cookies yeah yeah
yeah kind of they're not like super
super sweet but that's kind of what's
good about them in coffee yeah that's
kind of what that one for like the
holidays
that's kind of what the I was reading an
article the other day because I used to
think this was really fun danish cookies
is that what it called potatoes cookie
isn't that what we call them oh I don't
know
Maybe
but um
but I was reading an article the other
day and this kind of cracked me up
because
the first time that I went to the UK I
had always kind of wondered about this
too because you know how in the UK like
they have biscuits which are kind of
like what we would call cookies but um
and they call them digestives
and um
and I was like they really should change
the names of that they should change the
name of that because it's like it
doesn't sound real advertising but
they're actually like really really good
and I especially I got really into them
they sell them over here too sometimes
uh sometimes you can find them like if
you go to Publix uh especially in
Florida because there's a lot of British
tourists and a lot of British people
live here
um you can usually find like a small
section of British groceries
um and they will usually have that they
don't usually have hobnobs because
hobnobs are my favorite because they're
kind of like more OD you know I mean
they have they're almost like oatmeal
cookies but they're not super sweet
they're not super sweet because you're
supposed to like dip them in tea is what
they're
you know you have them with tea is what
you're supposed to do but they have ones
that have like chocolate on them too and
those are also good somebody's asking
this in Chile South America no chili is
Indian
pretty sure like chili powder and
chilies
I mean uh
we go to the Indian
Spice Market what's that what's the name
of that place Spice World Spice World
and they got a [__] ton of chili pouch
just like the movie about the Spice
Girls that one that cashmere was it was
it cashmere chili which was hot as [__]
was in the kashmiri
another name yeah I think that yeah
that's the brand name didn't we buy that
big bag of it of the chili powder and
yeah that [__] was like [__] it was
called kashmiri chili powder set your
mouth on fire it was not
it's hot
it's say like cayenne pepper
but hotter than red regular red chili
powder
it's still red but it's just kind of a
it's not a deep red it's just like a
bright red [__] was good but it had both
cons
so when Texans from back in the day were
saying that chili was Indian
I thought it was Native Americans what
they were talking about I was thinking
no I think India Indian because Texas
and the South has a big Spanish
influence in Spain the Spanish Empire so
the British Empire too they knew all
about India and the [__] the spices
that could come from India
so yeah Texas would would have known
about Indian food
in the eight in late 1800s early 1900s
they would have known about it
it would have been rare and exotic
but you look at a chili recipe
chili con carne
it looks like a fusion of Indian food
Mexican food
and toxic and Texican was the kind of
Germans you know German and Irish people
and it just looks like
it's Curry
the basic recipes Curry
and I think that's what they did and it
didn't have beans in it
real Texans is just beef
so that's beef Curry yeah
Indians would need beef but we're not
talking about Indians
we're talking about Texans
they'll throw a moo cow in there and a
heartbeat a whole cow whole [__] cow
still moving Moon and everything
yeah yeah Tammy's uh Biscoff cookies
yeah that's what they're called that's
the name that's because like I said they
used to on Virgin Atlantic Airlines like
the transatlantic flight they used to
give us gaji says there's a curry that's
English I Like It Hot our local Indian
restaurant is the business yeah also
says hobnobs are good but they're not
rich tea yeah Rich tea are good too
although I have to say that my favorite
uh cookies biscuits whatever that I ate
over there were custard creams yeah I
loved those so much that I bought like a
[__] ton of them and brought them back
in my suitcase last time I went there
because it's like it's you can get
um digestive biscuits you can get um
all that stuff you can sometimes you can
get hobnobs over here like it depends
and actually the Indian market that we
go to has like a British section also
that has like a bunch of the cookies and
candy bars and whatnot
um but it's hard to find custard creams
I think they did have some some they do
have some sometimes but it's it's kind
of a hit or miss whether you can get
them or not but I really like those
um Zach asked the Brits aren't known for
their uh cooking I guess he's saying but
what was uh your fave food from the UK
I'm gonna defend the British the British
are known for cooking they do have some
good they do have good stuff yeah they
do I actually really like the food over
there yeah and a lot of the Amer a lot
of American Cuisine is actually based on
British stuff
um the problem was is that the British
got a bad reputation for food especially
like in the 60s and 70s
when they were [__] in a bad economic
problem they were a lot of them were
eating out of cans there wasn't a lot of
[__]
choices and um
uh [__] foreign food wasn't available
there so they didn't have Mexican food
or anything but all that you know
they're updated now you think you can
pretty much get anything in England as
far as I know yeah it's not the same
world it's just like anywhere else yeah
yeah but no the Indian the English were
good at like things like meat pies pies
[__]
um
dealing with roasting things yeah
they're real good at that
um
fish and chips come on
um I could live on fishing yeah they got
some good [__] and then they'd probably
get scurvy yeah some [__]
the thing is is that British food was
never really spicy their version of
spicy food would have been English
curries that was like their version of
Mexican food but the thing about it is
they love Indian food and like and
they've honestly Indian food is like
essentially just English food at this
point because you can get you go you go
in a fish and chip place and they have
Indian food like yeah it's kind of like
how Mexican food and Italian food is now
American food yeah it's the same kind of
thing
um honestly one of my favorite things I
love um Cornish pasties yeah
um and I especially like they had a
great one I had one over there in uh I
think it was in Cardiff I guess and I
had one that was
pork and apple like in the crust and
everything like that holy [__] that was
so good yeah that was really good and I
was also really into the classic
Sunday dinner you know what I mean the
roast and the potatoes and the um and
the um Yorkshire puddings and yeah all
that I liked all that too the British
basically invented what we would call
breakfast too and their chocolate is
amazing yeah I really liked it I love
Walnut whips
um I love the arrow bar with the mint in
the middle I love that [__] the American
breakfast is basically a modified
British breakfast eggs bacon toast
they usually have tomatoes and beans
with theirs yeah which one and sometimes
blood pudding that wouldn't fly no thank
you but uh I've I've seen videos
of Brits coming here eating American
food and American breakfast they love
American but they instantly get it
do not I mean American breakfast I can't
I it's I can't eat it all because it's
like too much yeah but breakfast food is
the best food there's a good video on
YouTube where uh Southern dude takes two
British guys to [__] Waffle House at
two o'clock in the morning and they're
all drunk and they [__] loved it well
I mean that's kind of how you have to
get a Waffle House you don't go there in
the middle of the day sober yeah nobody
and the dude that took them is like a
[__] respected Chef American chef
and he goes no no no no because the best
breakfast is Waffle House at two o'clock
in the morning so he takes a while to
and and they order basically everything
the [__] yeah they're uh [__] well
biscuits and eggs
they got all the [__]
[__] hash browns with [__] gravy
although I will say that Waffle House
their grits aren't great no no actually
he said that he says grits no not here
yeah don't get the Grits at Waffle House
yeah everything else is good but their
grits are very very Bland right yeah
yeah he goes he goes That's the only
thing they don't have and I love Chef
said the same thing said that that their
grits suck I love grits but don't get
them at Walgreens pancakes with syrup
but all their other [__] is good they
couldn't eat it all he was just show
well yeah they ordered them what it was
and they were their minds were blown
they were like yeah this is uh
they would say the same thing as this is
a British breakfast yes but it's just
not that steroids and it's a different
version of it and uh they instantly got
it they said all that [__] would fly in
England they said that people in England
would love all that [__] they loved it
well and honestly the best thing for me
still
um staying in a hotel like any kind of
reasonably priced hotel that you stay at
will usually have an all-you-can-eat
breakfast buffet yeah so if you get down
there before it's usually 9 or 10 a.m
they have a whole thing set up man
there's a Pancake Station an omelette
station they got grits they got bagels
they got cereal they got eggs they got
uh everything yeah scrambled eggs
everything
then they got biscuits yeah and then
they would have [__] um English mug
we call them English muffins they got
everything they got fruit they got
oatmeal anything anything you can think
of spices Donuts yeah I used to go down
there and [__] and you can eat as
much as you want toast up some English
muffins put cream cheese on both of them
scrambled eggs bacon and man that sounds
good yeah and then close it in there and
make a [__] breakfast sandwich and
then they usually have yogurts in there
too a couple of yogurt anything you can
think of that you would eat for
breakfast and a couple things you
probably didn't think they had boiled
eggs you take three or four of those
hard-boiled eggs you put them in your
pocket
with the hard-boiled eggs eat them later
cold
well it's like I'm still gonna eat it
it's not going to waste you're not
stealing it yeah I mean that's part of
your eggs in a cargo pot Dandy wings
[Laughter]
that's what we were doing fishing trips
sometimes down the coast
honestly like I said I can legitimately
say that's my favorite thing about
staying in a hotel it's like we have to
get up early they have all you can eat
breakfast and you just get overwhelmed
like I know I can't even eat it all yeah
like I can't even eat a fraction of it
yeah but I just like the idea yeah and
then usually if it's like Best Western
or the kind of those kind of places yeah
yeah yeah
um they uh the staff there is like no
tear that [__] up because we're gonna
throw it away because it's never all eat
it's never yeah it's never finished it's
kind of wasteful and wasteful sure
nobody nobody eats all of it there's
always some left they thought they gotta
throw it away
they evidently the staff takes a lot of
that [__] home well that's good at least
at least somebody's eating it yeah but
yeah it's like the last time I think
like when we stayed at that hotel with
um Jen and Dimitri yeah when we went to
the castle so we stayed at a hotel in
Tampa I don't what it wasn't Best
Western it was um
[__] Hotel was it Dimitri worked for
them
I can't remember what chain it was it
was it was one of the better ones yeah
one of the one of the slightly better
change it's not like fancy fancy but it
was like you know it was underneath
Hilton I think
yeah it might have been a Hilton
actually now that I'm thinking about it
yeah it says scones I think it's I think
uh oh I love scones yeah I think an
English bones with strawberry jam and
clotted cream I think an American
English muffin is a a cheap scum I think
isn't that right we saw a thing they
don't um they're similar but they don't
taste quite the same yeah it's like a
bad executed scone no no no no no no
English muffin they were trying to do um
what was it they were trying to do a um
uh uh what do you call it
Right Out of My Head not a scone it was
some that doesn't exist in America no no
it's we you can get them here it's just
like
the story that they said back in the
early 1900s it wasn't a well-known thing
so they couldn't use the British name
for it they called it an English muffin
which is something that Americans would
go okay
all right it's like a muffin and it's
from England why didn't I forget what
those are called I forgot what what the
British version of the name was I'll
remember it
Crumpet thank you Crumpet so crumpet
and yeah if you see a crumpet a taste of
Crumpet that's a lot more similar okay
the English muffin like like over here
like Thomas's that's the biggest brand
yeah and they're sourdough yeah so good
ones and if you toast them right they're
nice and crispy and stuff like that but
crumpets are
slightly denser okay
um but there are similar
um it's a similar size and like a
similar thickness okay ours are a little
lighter then
yeah a little bit but it's very similar
so it was kind of like the American
version of The Crumpet okay but nobody
knew what a crumpet was back then but
maybe they don't know they would know
now yeah maybe not I have bought them
here before but it's like but they go oh
an English muffin
because yeah that's what they were
trying that's what they learned I like
crumpets though that sounds like I'd
like one you probably would I like it
yeah well it's just like I said it's
very similar to an English muffin
although I will say that like English
muffins
um
I don't know I think I like those better
just because they have like all those
like air pockets in them and like when
you toast them they get kind of crunchy
on the edges and kind of absorb butter
real well yeah and I'm kind of you can
put jam on there an English muffin
that's what they use for for the classic
McDonald's breakfast sandwiches which
you know had been like that for years
and years that's like yeah England and
you would know what an American English
muffin is it's on that damn [__]
Eggman muffin yeah because I think the
Egg McMuffin is the same yeah it's just
not in the UK thing before they put it
on there but it doesn't matter
well it depends an American crumpet
yeah it's very similar yeah I don't I've
got crumpets here before but I don't
remember where I got them probably easy
to make
I think I've made them before too
um I can't remember where I bought where
did I buy them I can't remember if I
bought them like at a Publix or if I
bought them at like an English because
where I grew up there actually used to
be
a British tea room and then in the back
they had like a little wall of groceries
that you could buy and sometimes they
had crumpets and things like that
so
take that Crumpet put a slice of ham on
it
American cheese
and some egg
that was McDonald's version of the
[__] eggs benedict
it worked though
I will argue they didn't have anything
that any [__] holiday sauce on it
though I will argue that the sausage
McMuffin with egg is superior to the Egg
McMuffin
I like them both well they're both good
I'm not saying they're not both good I'm
just saying that
given the choice I will always pick the
sausage but because I like the sausage
on their like interaction with the egg
better than I do the ham that's on the
Egg McMuffin yeah
but I don't know I mean the sausage
muffin with egg is just like I feel like
that's like the platonic ideal of like
the breakfast sandwich you know what I
mean no it's funny
is that they got the filet of fish
sandwich right and it's got cheese on it
yeah which is usually it does not go on
fish it's usually something that's kind
of a No-No yeah cheese doesn't go on
fish
but it's on there
I eat it I don't complain it works yeah
well it's a mild cheese it's just
American cheese right yeah American it's
not even more cheese
American cheese product it's way way
whey protein
I will note that one other place where
I've seen that done and I don't even
know where this comes from but at the
Chinese buffet not
um I don't think Ichiban has it but um
koi won has it
they do this kind of
baked
kind of a casserole situation and it's
like chunks of crab meat
and they bake it but it has kind of like
I don't know if it's like bread crumbs
like a sprinkling breadcrumbs and then
it has cheese on it not sure what kind
of cheese it is I don't think it's
mozzarella
and it's not flavorful enough to be
cheddar it might be American cheese for
all I know
um might be Velveeta it could be
mozzarella but I don't remember I don't
eat in a long time but um but that works
because I've eaten that before but it's
like I feel like if you're gonna pear
fish and cheese it usually has to be
like a pretty mild cheese
they don't usually like I I'm Gonna
Stand
um where I was before
and say
cheese does not belong on Fish It
generally does not I will agree no
although the filet of fish sandwich
that's an exception they just put that
cheese on there because they had it and
they had to have something on there it
doesn't you can't really taste it
honestly yeah
it's and I don't tell them to leave it
off
I accept it on there but it doesn't
really belong it doesn't really belong
fish doesn't belong on cheat on on
excuse me cheese doesn't belong on a
fish if you want to call that cheese
that's not really cheese
do they still do the double stack uh uh
filet of fish now you just order it
double Flair fish they'll give it to you
it's not on the menu because okay well
it was for a while yeah
um there's a lot of stuff that you can
ask for that that well yeah that's how
it was everybody's just like orders [__]
off yeah there's a bunch of stuff you
can secret menus and [__] that's just on
the app and all that other okay stop did
you just ask for a double Flair fish
they'll give it to you because you I
don't think I ever got one but you said
that that was actually Superior yeah
because the fish to bread ratio is
always much better yeah that's the way
which I can see that that's the way to
eat a flavor fish double Flair fish
it tastes more like fish
or you know it's more substantial
you know I used to like and this was a
long time ago I'm kind of showing my age
but back in the day
um Burger King which I'm not a huge fan
of but Burger King used to have a big
ass fish sandwich called the whaler yeah
they're still out there
um they don't call it no it's not they
don't they don't have the whaler anymore
they still have a fish sandwich but they
call it something else but I don't know
what it's called the fish sandwich they
have now I think is okay like I think I
had it a year or two ago and it was all
right yeah but the one they used to have
back in the day was actually really good
and it was massive it was like I
remember it being like really really big
Burger King's not what it was
it's not as good as it used to be
now we went to that one quite regularly
it was always a little substandard
McDonald's was a lot better
yeah we always the thing about it is
like I never really seek out BK yeah but
it's just kind of like I won I always
had coupons for it because we always got
coupons in the mail yeah so I always had
coupons and the food was really cheap
and it was one of the few places that
was like easy to get to like on the way
to the movie theater like from our old
house so a lot of times we would go in
there and it was usually not crowded
there was usually nobody in there so
it's one of the fast food is [__]
wind is Wendy's probably honestly I'm
yeah out of the big three yeah
um Wendy's was always my favorite I
haven't been there in a while so I don't
know what their offerings are like
nowadays the thing is though is I'll
have a [__] a desire a calling from
McDonald's and I never get that with
Wendy's
there's something about it
I just had to have a damn Big Mac you
know so well they well McDonald's has a
very very distinctive flavor profile
certain flavor
and it's like sometimes I want that too
like I said we used to sell this
probably why we gained so much weight
over that one time period but like when
we used to live in Sanford and literally
right around the corner from my house it
was a McDonald's and for a long time it
was open 24 hours so it's like every
time we were coming home from the club
and we were a little bit inebriated and
we were kind of hungry because we hadn't
eaten for a long time and we were drunk
and we were just kind of like man you
know it sounds good right now let's get
some [__] McDonald's so we'd always
like stop and get McDonald's like on the
way home
but we haven't eaten there is uh there's
not a McDonald's around here yeah really
like I said there's not which which is
probably no no there's one here I mean
there is but it's not like a street for
Starbucks it's not like super convenient
across the street from Starbucks yeah
across the street from where the booze
we bought the booze at one time but see
how many miles away is that though uh
seven eight miles per hour see it's like
a while yeah so it's like where we lived
in Sanford it was literally it was like
you could walk to it yeah look it's
after 10 I'm getting sleepy you want to
go ahead and shut this down oh [__] is
it really yeah oh my God and like you
totally forgot okay and I gotta take an
injection oh yeah that's right yeah I
forgot about that yeah I'm pretty sure I
didn't I didn't pretty sure I didn't
shoot up I mean yesterday I think that
was Wednesday
shooting up again yeah it's just like
I can't well you need to write the [__]
down because I can't remember if you did
that or not it's like I don't want you
like doubling up on this [__] it doesn't
matter if I go over a little bit oh it
doesn't matter I can handle it but I I'm
pretty sure I didn't
pretty sure I didn't well I don't
remember so don't look at me
I don't think I did I don't think I
don't think I I don't think I took a
dose yesterday
oh Zach says I had a Breakfast
Crunchwrap from Taco Bell this morning
and I think that's my favorite fast food
item at the moment I haven't been a Taco
Bell in a million Taco Bell kind of
comes and goes
she showed me another one that was
better Del Taco
yeah Del Taco there's only two of them
in Orlando yeah there was one where I
near kind of where I used to live like
when I lived by myself
I used to like it because they had tacos
and french fries which I thought was
kind of cool they had Del Taco when I
was a little kid out in California but
yeah back then no it's pretty good I
like the chicken tacos actually but I'd
say I'm eating there back in the 70s Del
Taco sucked
Taco Bell's a lot better just like
everything else everybody kind of had it
up their game you can't get away with
[__] you got away with in the 70s
another thing that they had back in the
late 70s early 80s that I [__] loved
was a [__] um
was a jack-in-the-box tacos Jack in the
Box had tacos looks like they deep-fried
the whole thing with the salad oh yeah I
never had that but I heard about it and
it was kind of like they were the
shittiest tacos
shitty shitty [__] Taco they were
delicious well you deep fry anything
yeah that's pretty good you know what I
mean it's like a bean paste with a
little bit of meat in it folded over
with some kind of cheese and then they
put the lettuce in there and they folded
the thing over like that pretty sure
they [__] deep fried it with the
lettuce in it
not gonna lie I didn't eat that and it
was like sealed together I need that it
was sealed up in there that sounds
pretty good like it was almost like a
like a like a deep fried
corn
chimichanga or something it was good
good it didn't it did not taste like a
taco
it tasted like something else but they
were cheap they were like 50 cents a
piece back then she could get like four
or five of them for you know a couple
well yeah I mean like for you for the
broke ass Studio yeah something like
that it's like whole day's calories on
this [__] yeah and they came for like
five dollars
and then um yeah
I don't know whatever happened to that
that didn't go National I guess there's
just not enough of them yeah that's
mostly like out west right I don't think
we ever had any here parties sucks now
every time you go to Hardee's it's
substandard Hardees used to be really
good I was a kid here in the South now I
will maintain that the biscuits are
still good but everything else is uh not
not great I remember it's just very why
bother yeah
in the uh all the way up until like the
mid 90s early 90s Hardy's had
its own
flavor and it was its own experience it
was
very different from the other ones but
it was good I would better than I would
say better than McDonald's you know
better than Burger King it was it was
tight it was really good
I had a real strong char-boiled flavor I
think everything was charbroil or they
added Char-Broil flavoring to it but the
problem I've had with it hard is every
time I went to one of the [__] meat
Patty tastes like soybean it's really
cheap meat
yeah they probably just started cheaping
out yeah well and that might be because
they're not getting
uh you know they're not bringing in the
same uh money that they used to so it's
like they're you know it just it's a
downward spiral you see with a lot of
restaurants it's like well we're not
getting all the people coming in here we
don't have as much money so we're gonna
cheap out on the ingredients and that
makes less and less people come in so
you just start smiling yeah they're in
7-Elevens yeah
we got a Super Chat yeah all right from
Cal thank you very much what do you say
and look it's at nothing but it says
celebrate the first Super Chat
from Cala Calhoun thank you very much
thank you very much that's the first
that's the first time I've ever seen
that little thing come up yeah that's my
that's my little Hopper boy
I think
I think that's a new account name oh
okay
he says gotta bounce you guys always
make my day oh that's so nice of you
I mean we have a good time talking to
you guys like I said my Friday the
Friday night show is my favorite one I
always look forward to it but yeah it is
kind of I didn't realize it yeah it's
getting late I didn't realize it was
that late all right so we're gonna knock
off for the day yeah we will be back on
Monday evening talking about a movie we
don't know what movie yet because we
haven't even thought of which one we're
gonna watch so it'll be just as much of
a surprise to us as to you probably not
quite but you know what I mean but so
yeah so hopefully you guys can
come by and join us we're going to talk
about whatever movie that's going to be
and have a good weekend everybody and we
will see you guys on Monday
good night